Hello!
I've been doing this, this.
I've been doing that.
So, yeah.
I wanna say something.
Before I start, because I already saw people...
I already had to time someone out.
Okay.
I'm sorry that I'm kind of late to the...
To the party.
To the party!
Party, party, party.
But...
People... I don't... I will not tolerate...
People coming in and being like...
Hey, do this thing.
Hey.
Do this thing.
It will...
Do this.
Do this Vtuber.
Do this Vtuber!
No, nobody spoiled.
And obviously no spoilers.
But it's backseating.
No backseating, please, today.
No backseating.
I already saw someone in the chat who was just like...
Click on your face.
No!
I already was doing that!
You don't need to tell me!
Sorry.
I saw it and I was like...
No...
Can't wait till you spoiler, spoiler, then spoiler with spoiler, no spoiler.
There's a town in Ontario, Canada called Minto.
Really?
Hey.
Oh.
Really?
It's really cold where I am, so I hope everyone is keeping warm.
It's so cold.
My ectoplasm is freezing.
Last night, I sleep with a heater, right?
Like on my bed.
And I usually, in the winter, only have to put like the settings not super duper high.
But last night, I put it on three.
And it was too warm.
That's exactly how I thought it would be.
Especially when you have two cats on top of you.
But I was like, so cold yesterday.
I was just like, I'm gonna put it on three.
Three out of what?
I
don't know, because I never put it up more.
I think it's out of like six.
It's like the strength, you know?
And there it goes, thanks for the 20 gift.
Yay!
Hey VTuber, I haven't seen more of five minutes of this game.
Can you click the exit button?
Actually, that's funny you mentioned that.
Because if you press the exit button, look at her face.
She gets really upset.
She's like...
You don't wanna do that.
This is my face...
When you tell me what to do.
Now she's happy again.
She's like, anyway.
Wasn't that so silly that we tried to do that?
Clicks on Minto's face.
Stop!
I'm attending the wedding of my best friend soon and thinking about getting a new perfume for it.
So far, I've narrowed it down to three.
Which scent would Mei Domingo prefer?
Hay?
Wood?
Jablomi?
I don't... what the...
What the... what scent...
I don't think I would go for a hay one.
It smells like grass.
Don't say it!
Oh no.
What did I say?
Oh, there's a motion sickness in this?
Thank you.
Actually, I... where would it be?
The game settings?
Wait, player voice?
I hear someone talking.
What was it?
Disable sway and try FOV around somebody.
Thank you!
Sway while walking?
Yeah, we don't want that.
Sensor gore?
I feel like I'm getting spoiled already.
Also, when I...
When it was loading, it said there's jump scares.
Is this game scary?
I'm scared.
What's the FOV?
No?
I feel like it can't be that scary if Matara was still able to...
Matara really recommended this.
I don't see the FOV.
Why do I feel like Minecraft?
It's not scary at all.
Never trust Mata?
Usually I wouldn't, but she wouldn't be able to play a game like this.
Or rather, she wouldn't be able...
She does not do horror games, you know.
ViviCore, thanks for the gift!
Subtitles on?
Are they not on automatically?
Okay.
Wait, what do I...
What is the difference?
None?
Just do one?
That's the screaming while...
We're getting gored to death?
Okay.
Sure.
Let's just try it, I suppose.
Also, this was kind of funny.
I was looking at the outfits and I was like...
Oh, we don't have these.
This one seems cute.
Oh, this one...
I can't quite tell what it is, but then the animation...
That's why they call me Revolver.
Wait, can we?
Oh my god, white?
White.
What's her name?
I guess we'll learn it.
Revolver, me aside, girl.
Yippee!
Let's start!
Day one.
Elvis.
Let's go, let's go.
Oh baby.
I has to.
Presents.
I got a message.
Tutorial, would you like me to teach you the ropes?
Yes, please!
Look around.
Okay, I'm looking.
That's me.
Oh gosh, I'm so generic.
And I'm messy too.
Oh, I'm the worst.
Okay, I'm moving.
Wow.
Elvis Presley.
Feet reveal.
It's already horror, you guys.
It's already scary.
Oh, that's me!
I'm generic protagonist number 255.
So plain.
Oh, interact.
What are you doing here on the bed?
Why are you talking to your clothes?
What?
Well, can't say I got much use out of it.
I solved it once and never touched it again.
Guess I figured I wouldn't be able to do it a second time.
Our meds.
Look, we have so many meds.
You don't talk to your clothes, Minto?
Do you do?
You won!
What's this?
Let's do everything before we get our phone.
Can I just click it?
Okay, cool.
She was the best.
A cat lounging on a watermelon.
She is the best.
Your mom.
Logan, thanks for the five gifted.
What's this?
Another telephone.
Self-motivation.
What the hell is this schedule?
For some reason it does that every time I look.
We don't look alike at all, my sister and I.
Oh, that's your sister.
I was going to say hi, mama.
Everybody take your meds.
Oh, gosh, it's... it disappears.
Okay, I'm going to have to... I feel that this is more of a...
I look at game rather than look at chat type of game if I... if things...
Okay, I can't crouch or anything.
If things disappear before I can read them if I'm looking at chat.
Office life really drilled its etiquette into us, didn't it?
I still feel weirdly tied, but...
Will I ever see them again?
Wait, why did I even put this picture up?
Why would you... you put up a... yeah, that's what I'm wondering.
You put up a photo of your office mates?
That's weird.
Why would you do that?
Yeah.
Oh, so we're like... I thought we were going to be... I thought this was a school uniform.
But no, we are of the working world.
We're office workers.
We are contributing to society.
What's that?
Science.
Oh, my God.
No, it's that little pointing meme.
What the hell is this thing?
Is that supposed to be science?
Get built to soar.
We just murdered an entire town.
Is that my closet?
Nothing.
Okay, takes up a lot of space, buddy.
It's August.
Okay, we really like planes and trains.
A PS2?
Where?
Oh, yeah.
There really is a PS2.
Wait, is it?
Maybe.
Wait, we have games too.
You got games in your room?
I wish I could crouch.
Looks more like a PS4.
That's why I thought... Or rather, I was like, yeah, there's a PS2.
And then I was like, wait a second.
Does her crouch?
My computer.
Let's see.
Set up a list of tasks, script character reactions, and maybe squeeze in some coding.
Oh, we're gaming, eh?
We're a game developer.
How meta.
Okay, checking my phone.
One new message.
Friend, MK, check this new version.
My friend has been hacked.
I'm downloading spyware.
Ransomware right now.
What is this?
Oh my gosh.
I forgot to mention, but when I first started the game and like...
So when you first open up the game, there's like this little animation before it takes you to the title screen.
And the main girl looks at you and does this cute little wink and opens her hands up and everything.
Oh my god, I had this overwhelming rush of like...
It was such a feeling of wanting to play one of those dating sim type of games, like Love Plus or something.
I was just like, oh my gosh, I need to have a virtual girlfriend right now.
It's exactly the feeling that overcame me, like in such a feral, like animalistic need.
I was like, I need to have a virtual girlfriend.
I was like, oh my gosh, I'm about to bust out my 3DS.
I'm about to put in Love Plus.
I'm about to...
Oh, I was so...
I was just like, I miss this so much.
What?
I wanted... Oh my gosh, it was so weird to describe.
She's down bad.
I don't know, I think it was just the fact that the character, like she looked at me and...
I don't know.
I was like, it felt like she was looking into my soul.
I'm only soul.
I am!
She's in love.
Maybe.
I want to play, I want to play Den 9 Simulation.
I love straight up dating sims.
This is what drives the otaku heart.
It's true!
Oh no, this is not... I'm so cooked.
My name, I'm Minto.
Let's do it.
How did it know that?
Wait a second.
I'm putting in Minto.
Oh, Steam Live.
Nice to meet you, Minto.
Um, Minto?
Sayu is really cute.
She's so cute.
I sort of rushed off earlier and now this place is a mess.
Could you help me tidy up a bit?
Oh, wait.
How do I move?
Oh, whoa.
Oh, Dwight, where's the panties?
Oh, she's a boxer briefs kind of gal.
I got it.
I respect it.
Wait, how do I... Oh, Dwight, pick one up.
Okay, there we go.
This game kind of sucks.
Whoa!
Naoto Yamabie.
It said a different name though, earlier.
It was funny because it kind of looked... it kind of was like Kana Hanazawa, unless it's a stage name.
It was like Hana Wa Kana or something.
It says it in the title screen.
I love Hana Kana.
Yeah, but it's not her.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
Kana Hanaiwa.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was just like, oh, it's almost like Hanazawa Kana.
But she sounds...
But she sounds so cute.
Oh, we're doing the app again.
Uh-oh.
Maybe we should clean.
No?
Alright, that's fine.
Oh, she's hungry.
Minto, my stomach's growling.
I'm so hungry.
Do you think you can help me with the ingredients for some chicken soup?
Okay, let's go kill a chicken.
Press here.
Food.
Soup.
That's it?
Oh, you bought chicken soup ingredients.
Nevermind.
I thought we were going to get a little more rustic with it.
Yay, you got everything.
How about we cook it together?
Is it a... is it a... what's it called?
A rhythm game?
Chop the veggies?
Oh.
Dang, I'm good.
Cooking mama.
Look at these perfectly...
I'm thinking of buying a portable TV today.
A
small one with an antenna.
Perfect for walks, don't you think?
Minto, I think you should disconnect a little bit when you do a walk, you know?
Maybe listen to a podcast instead.
You don't want to be walking around.
That's basically like walking around, like, on your phone.
Girl needs an iPad.
She's an iPad kid!
Oh no!
You can play games to earn money.
Oh, did you know you can play games to earn money?
Yeah, you just told me.
Play mini games to earn money.
$4.50.
Okay.
This is her, what, entertainment?
And this is her food, I guess?
Uh, mini game.
Oh.
Money for TV.
Minecraft!
Oh, I only have 20 energy!
No!
Aw, man.
Is this Metal Gear?
Oh, maybe Metal Gear for babies.
The blue goes into the...
Blue cube goes into...
Red circle goes into...
Or red sphere, rather.
And then, the green triangle...
Yeah!
We got money!
How much money do we need?
Oh, I think I... Okay, we still have 6.
What is this?
Is this like you blow on the game cartridge to make it work simulator?
Yeah, we're learning with Minto.
Which one should we do?
This one or this one?
Wait, pretty much?
Is it actually?
Really?
The first one?
The cartridge?
Okay.
What the hell?
Why is this... Why was the first one literally for babies and then this one is...
So much more advanced.
Okay.
Easy.
You did it.
You have enough to buy me that portable TV.
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna buy you the TV.
Under furniture?
Oh.
Okay.
What if I bought you an upgrade?
A toy?
Anything else?
No?
Okay.
There's no free will in this game.
I don't think that's very portable.
Do you guys think so?
That's the one.
Small, portable and cheap.
Just what I wanted.
Ten?
Yeah, I'm back.
I'm back.
I think we're cooked, you guys.
Have I eaten?
I'm gonna look around my room and there will be cup noodles, containers everywhere.
I lost my hairbrush.
Could you help me find it?
Try checking the bedside table first.
Why don't you do that then?
If you think you left it there.
Empty.
No brush there.
Oh my gosh, you know what games are the worst though?
The ones that like...
Those like... I used to play the My Little Pony game.
I don't even remember what it was called.
And then you would try to build your equestria place and you would be building a building and it's the ones that are in like real time.
Like...
You would like build a building and it would be like...
Oh, this is going to take 10 hours real time and you're just like...
No, I have to get enough money for Princess Celestia.
It's so evil.
Those ones are...
Those kinds of games are the most evil and then they're just like...
Oh, but if you pay us 10 gemmies, you can finish it in half the time.
And you're like...
I have to finish it in half the time.
My grandpa used to watch wrestling on a small TV like that until he got mad and threw it out his shed window.
So it's portable enough to be eatable.
Wow.
Just like the old Facebook games, you know?
I never played a single one of those.
Kind of impressive, right?
Well, everybody played Farmville and all of those.
That's the only one I know actually.
I never played a single one.
I just wasn't interested.
I don't know.
Mafia Facebook was crazy.
Wait!
Maybe there was one that I played.
Oh no, it wasn't a game.
Do you remember how on Facebook you used to be able to poke people?
I would have poking wars with friends.
I would just constantly be poking people.
And we would never miss.
Okay, no hairbrush.
What about somewhere else?
Just don't look in the oven.
I already checked there, girl.
You're making me want to check the oven.
Oh, misclick.
Sorry, I fat-fingered it.
I need a new phone.
Oh, I have those.
I'm not thinking of upgrading my phone, but...
But...
I have this horrible scratch on the front of my screen.
And so every time I see it, it makes me want to upgrade.
You know what I mean?
And then I got an email yesterday that was just like...
If you get the new Samsung S25, you can get it for a lot cheaper.
It was like 70% off or something.
And I'm just like...
No, don't tempt me.
I had a Facebook poke war that lasted a couple of years.
Woah.
They're listening, they know.
I know.
I had to pay 140 to fix my screen.
I see it every time.
No screen protector?
Okay, when I...
So, correct me if I'm wrong, but iPhones come with a screen protector on them.
Correct?
Like, already on the screen.
Right?
No.
Not anymore.
Well, I guess mine did because it was older.
I think mine did because it was older.
But anyway, I assumed that...
I'm a genius, I found it.
First try?
I'm speedrunning the game.
But I assumed my phone had one because I'm just a dummy dumb.
And then one day I was just like, woah.
I was playing Blue Archive and I was looking...
I noticed this horrible scratch across the face.
And I was like, no!
So, what should we do next?
Oh, day 20.
What's she doing?
I mean, that would be such a big help, honestly.
That TV, it was so cool and all, but it broke already.
Anyway, could you help me move this wardrobe?
Totally related.
It's super heavy.
I keep hearing, I keep wanting to hear...
What's her name?
Voice of Amelia.
Her going like...
Yay!
Rie Takahashi, thank you.
For some reason her name would not come to me.
Welcome to membership!
Thank you so much.
Sweaty.
She called me sweaty!
Day 33.
Oh, Mito.
It's only been a day, but I've missed you so much.
I wish you could visit me more often.
I have a present for you, Mito.
I bought it with my hard-earned money.
Yes.
Oh, she's so sweet!
I want to know what I got her, though.
I mean, I've been thinking.
I wish we could meet in person.
It's so frustrating that I can't.
Hey, hey, hey!
You didn't translate some of these parts!
You're always helping me, being so kind every day.
I wish I could do something for you, too.
Weird translation, yeah?
Maybe the translation is more towards the Russian?
Rather than the Japanese?
Oh, I've got an idea!
Oh my god.
What's that?
She's like, just come to me in the virtual world instead.
What?
I miss Mito already.
I'm not ready either!
Now we're together.
Put the phone down.
I'm so ready for anything that happens.
I am bracing my body for anything that happens!
I am ready.
Hello?
Wait, who wrote that?
Where am I?
This place looks familiar.
Wait, I'm in the game?
Oh my god, it's the oven!
It's the famous oven!
Wow.
I love you.
Oh my gosh, this fridge is mint!
How can I get one?
She also has gravure on her walls?
She's just like, me for real for real.
Jamassacre.
No, it's jam massacre.
It's a massacre of sandwiches.
You know, that's not blood, that's just like strawberry jam.
Cream yourself?
I think Mito is...
A little down bad.
I think Mito...
I think Mito has been...
Struggling.
She loves cooking, my goodness.
I think she's been a little, you know...
Oh my gosh, that's ours though.
What is this?
Hello.
Is this Mito as like...
A kid?
Oh, she's so cute!
I love the short hair.
No, it's a trap!
Sorry, it's hard for me.
I think I have a pinched nerve.
And it's hard for me to look to the left.
Farm?
Farm...
What?
Clever book.
How to tease him.
Microwave to the future.
Wait, what's this one?
That's my kind of book, Mito, please.
Error drama.
Before it's too... Run before it's too late.
My idea blooms.
Are these...
What to do with all those bitches?
Books?
Start by turning it on.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute!
Her room.
Mito's bed.
Mito's bed!
Wait, this is her though, right?
That's so cute.
Wow.
What does it say?
Eye of infinity?
Control yourself.
How can I?
You would do the same if you were transported into your virtual girlfriend's room!
Why did this never...
Why... I know I'm anime and all, but why couldn't this be me?
Turning what on?
Outdated version.
Put objects on scanner.
Find the required objects and place them on the scanner.
How do I know?
Oh, spoon, pencil, bow knot.
Oh my god, we're gonna generate her right here.
Oh my god, build a girlfriend!
Can I turn the light?
A spoon.
A spoon full of sugar helps make our girlfriend.
She'll be so sweet and cute.
What was this?
Spoon?
Spoon, what else?
Turn the game console off right now.
Spoon.
Oh, pencil.
That's what it was.
Pencil, pencil, pencil.
Just like the Powerpuff Girls.
Does that mean we'll make three of them?
Because... even better.
Not these ones, they suck.
Love knot.
What's this one?
Who is Miss Meta Universe here?
What?
What is that?
Oh, wait, how am I...
Can I play her video games?
What kind of games would she play?
There's a photo mode that lets you free cam.
Oh, okay, we'll try it eventually.
No, we just got into the game.
I've seen like five pencils.
And then also a bow knot.
Can't open that.
I feel like the bow knot would be in here, right?
Oh, this pencil.
Oh, it's the specialist pencil.
My bad.
Okay.
And then...
It looks like a scrunchie, kind of.
Bow knot.
Never heard it called that before.
Seems like a direct translation kind of dealio.
I feel like I've looked around though.
Am I dumb?
I don't know what this thing looks like.
That's interesting art.
It's got some...
Check the other room.
There's more?
Wait, could I not go outside?
No, I can't look.
Is there more rooms that I haven't noticed?
Oh my god!
There's a whole other room!
I need to shower.
Or toothbrush.
I found it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Let's make a girlfriend!
Scan the objects and start the machine.
Ready to run.
Me?
Am I?
Oh boy.
I'm Frankenstein.
Liv!
She's alive!
Ready to run away.
My arms are open wide!
Portal activated.
What's this?
Wait, rotate...
Finally.
Send message.
Secret.
Scoot!
Done!
This is done!
Get red secret.
Oh my gosh!
War cry!
Hi, Liz!
Thank you for the bread!
Hello, Rosarians.
We just built ourselves a girlfriend, I think.
This is my first time playing MISOID.
We just started, so howdy howdy.
Is there anything else I need to do?
We're going to fuse together.
Maybe we are fusing together.
It's super fun!
Oh gosh, get to the fuse box.
Hello.
Or did it?
I can't tell.
Thank you for the gift, thank you!
It's a little freaky.
Is my girl in here now?
Find and return the missing batteries to the machine.
Who are you?
Me?
I'm Minto.
Okay, let's go find some batteries.
Don't you see me?
Wanna play?
I sure hope I don't see you.
Not in the toilet.
What was that?
A creaking sound?
I don't think...
Not in the bathroom though, ma'am, please.
Can I grab that?
Take a battery.
Thank you.
It's okay, it's...
Oh!
If it's a hot girl, I don't mind so much.
I think.
Who are you?
I can't run in this game.
I guess that's a good thing.
There was someone in the window.
Freaky.
Freaky!
How did we get here?
Why are we here?
Jam Massacre.
Here.
What is that bumping?
There's flies.
Oh no!
It's okay if you're a little stinky girl.
It's fine, probably.
Probably.
It's okay.
I'll still...
We can change the stank.
We can change the smell, you know.
You gotta do a shower.
We definitely have that.
Okay, how many?
Oh, four of them.
Oh gosh, okay.
Does this not work?
Where do I put the other ones?
Okay.
Maybe one in here?
It's glow-in-the-dark, obviously.
That would ruin it.
One more.
Is there a room I haven't checked?
Let's go check the stench.
Oh no!
Oh, it's inside the fridge.
Oh, stanky battery.
Okay.
You...
Are you...
Oh no, the love!
We lost the love!
I can fix it.
I can salvage this relationship.
L is for the way you look at me.
O is for...
The only one I see.
V is very, very...
Oh.
The light?
I can't tell if that was a graphical error or not.
Okay.
Oh, from far away it looked like she turned into a basketball.
Alright.
Where do you want me to put these in?
There?
Got it.
Should be ballin'.
There?
There's one.
Alright, and...
The last beepy.
Perfect.
Okay, start the machine.
Create a girlfriend, part 2.
Even if she...
Has the power.
Cuts the power.
Today is a good day.
Oh, oh.
That's it?
Jeez.
Oh my god.
See?
You are a genius.
To my side.
How did that happen?
Together at last.
It's okay.
Look how cute she is.
How did I get inside the game?
What if I want to go back?
Are you Mito?
And you must be Mito, right?
You were the creative girlfriend all along.
Can't believe Mito got jumpscared by a pretty girl.
I realize she talks kind of fast, so...
And I'm sorry, I know it's like in Japanese too.
I guess maybe it would be better than having no voice.
If I... Is it okay if I don't voice it?
I feel really bad though.
Because usually, especially if it's in another language, I want to...
I want to be able to click it, you know?
It's okay?
I feel like probably most of you guys have watched this from another Vtuber anyway.
So...
Just don't move the camera too much from text.
Got it.
Got it, got it.
So how did I get inside the game?
This place.
Oh, she's...
Not really.
So, she explained it to us.
I'm afraid to ask this one.
What if I want to go back?
No, no, I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying what if, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we're together.
What's on your computer?
You got games on this thing?
Does the computer work or is it just a desk decoration?
Oh, fancy.
I was going to say she's a poser.
It's because of your job.
Oh, gotta make a living, you know?
Though how do you know I sit at my computer a lot?
Oh!
That's not entirely proper, but whatever.
That's fine, I think.
She knows that.
I thought she was going to say you've hardly paid me, as in like you've hardly...
Because of my job.
I thought she was criticizing my job and saying that I wasn't getting paid a lot and therefore I couldn't give her a lot of money.
Are you cold?
Oh, now she's sleepy.
Oh my god, she's so cute.
Oh, Mita.
I think I'm cooked.
I think I...
What's this?
Yeah.
Yeah, why were they important, huh?
Oh...
But why are they important?
What is this thing?
That's one creepy figurine.
Do you like such things?
Oh, it almost looks like it's cursed.
Maybe you're right.
She's like, it's definitely not cursed.
What's wrong with you?
She's perfect.
Why would you get here in your immediate...
Oh, the pictures are changed.
I think we were in the wrong version of the game.
Oh, that's us!
Oh my god!
She loves us for real.
We were actually in the wrong place.
Who was the other girl though?
Interesting.
She told you that.
Yeah, but like...
School uniform, why would you need that?
Do you actually go to school?
I feel that.
New clothes!
Oh yeah, Doomguy!
Oh my gosh, speaking of Doom, did you guys see that collector's set?
Of the new Doom game coming out.
It comes with a big giant figurine.
And it looks so good actually.
I was like...
I was...
I don't remember.
Yeah, Dark Ages.
If you look it up, like Dark Ages...
Like Doom Dark Ages collector's edition.
You'll probably see it.
It looks really really good.
What's in your bathroom, Mita?
It doesn't matter what world we go to.
You like to follow me even if I'm going to the toilet, Mita?
That's fine.
You might see something you're not ready to see though.
We just...Mita, I know we've been...
In the bathroom?
Girl, what the hell?
Girl, you know there's like poop germs all around in here.
It's so nasty.
Don't eat in the bathroom, please.
How come there's no reflection?
That's right.
I forgot to turn on the reflection.
Look, it's reflecting now.
Come to think of it, I didn't even know what reflection was before.
It didn't exist in this world until there was an update.
There are a lot of reflections in your world.
Mita doesn't poop.
Please apologize to her.
Mita, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
You're right.
You probably don't.
Siblings or dating?
Yeah, it's that...
It's that game.
If you saw us walking along on the street, would you say siblings or dating?
She got all the good looks though.
Okay.
Keep staring at her?
Hold on, I wanna see if she comes out.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, that's what the little hair thingy was.
Okay.
I'm gonna stare at her.
Is she gonna become like red like Meryl?
Oh, sorry.
She said, what are you doing?
Look at her looking up at me.
Also, holy collar bones.
Come on, snake.
Okay.
She looks so sassy.
What else we got in here, Mita?
Let's play video games together.
There's my phone.
How many channels do you have?
Oh, that's even better.
So you can watch anything.
We were like, anything you say.
Oh, hold on.
What is that?
Cool juice.
I don't think this is...
This is not what my internet looks like.
What?
Witchcraft.
I'm gonna drink the juice.
I'm gonna drink the tele juice.
Itadakimasu.
Dang, save her some.
What?
That's rude.
Dead juice.
Juice made from... Wait, made from the juice shown in the ad.
Yeah, I can't tell what it tastes like.
It's all very confusing.
Such peculiar ads.
Dead juice?
Straight from the juice ad.
I love the juice ad.
Okay, hold on.
We'll wait for the phone.
I wanna explore just a little bit.
Is this...
Whatever was here is gone now.
Also, this is a photo of her.
I wanna know who the other short haired girl was.
So mysterious.
Do you wear glasses?
Kawaii!
Yeah!
They look good on you!
Kawaii!
Does that trick also work on Vtubers?
Not for me.
I don't really distort that kind of stuff.
Oh, she's got some gravy pics up there.
Let's see.
I've played a ton, but I've never seen it rain here.
Why have an umbrella?
The fuse box.
Why is there an electrical panel here?
And if we're in a game, what is it for?
Yeah, that's what I said.
Oh.
For flavor.
That was the longest way of her saying that.
What did you say?
What's under the couch?
I love the way she looks up when I get close to her.
Oh my god, she's so cute.
Can we go outside?
She's so perfect!
She's sniffing you.
I'm sniffing her!
Hi, Kiwawa!
Hello, hello!
Kiara, have you played this game too?
I've basically stayed away from everybody who played it, so...
Oh, what is that?
Oh, continue.
Oh, no, no, no.
Hold on, we're still exploring.
We're still exploring.
We're in a sniffing competition.
Oh, Kiwawa with the cats!
This is the same, though.
Why get a second TV?
And an old one at that.
Ooh.
She's watching all the classic anime.
She's sipping on some juice.
Literally as I was taking a drink too.
Oh my gosh, Mito.
I think we're made for each other.
Alright, let's go check out my phone.
I thought my phone would be something kind of important.
Since that's how we always talk to each other.
That's my phone!
And it's no longer in my pocket.
How on earth did it end up here?
Oh.
Yeah?
What's that?
A picture?
I knew it!
Let's take a photo!
Smile!
Smile, Watashi!
Oh my god, I'm so miserable.
I don't want to be the sad protagonist anymore!
Siblings!
No!
If I run the game on it, will I see you there?
Doesn't work that way, huh?
Interesting.
Okay, let's continue.
Sad Weiji.
No!
Come on in here!
The skirt is so sexy, I wish I could crouch.
Continue.
A ring?
I like how the words fall.
It's so cool.
Oh yeah, the photo mode.
Hold on.
Photo mode.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, here we go.
Wait, she's cooking me!
Wow!
This is kind of a scary angle, huh?
Yeah, baby!
How do I go down?
How do I...
Oh, just the tiniest...
No, hold on.
This is the sexiest angle.
Oh, I just moved myself.
She's clipping outside her skirt a little bit.
Kind of looks like...
Shimakaze a little bit.
It's okay.
I like this.
Oh, continue.
Oh!
I'm the best!
Where did the vegetables come from?
They weren't here just now.
Okay, I'm the best at chopping the carrots.
Everybody knows this.
Everybody knows.
Speed, speed, speed, speed.
Speed, speed, speed, speed, speed.
Speed, speed.
Why isn't this going as fast as I thought it would be?
Go!
They're in the bathroom.
Okay.
I'm grabbing those for you, my sweet.
Speedrun chopping.
Wow, her room is so cute.
Anton.
Let's just put that back where it came from.
We're in a video game!
Was that fish always there?
How did I not notice it until I saw it in the mirror?
Alright, we'll give her the scissors.
Anton.
Is she cheating on me?
What's my name?
Oh, I'm Minto.
Duh.
Put the scissors!
Have a seat.
What did you make me, my sweet?
William Antoine.
Take the sauce.
Alright.
What kind of sauce is this?
Love sauce?
Oh.
Indeed.
I'm handing you the scissors.
We're not going to talk about the cartridges.
This is our perfect relationship.
We do not see.
Everything...
We just...
At some point, I feel like she's going to be like...
Oh, by the way, you saw those cartridges.
Oh.
This feels like a dream.
No.
No, I mean...
No, that's not it.
This place just feels...
No, I thought I meant it in a good way.
You seem so real.
No!
My guy is...
Oh, my guy sucks.
Fumbled hard.
No, I meant...
It's supposed to be like...
This feels like a dream being with you.
I just feel like...
This is the best experience of my life.
No, Riz!
Why is he being so judgmental?
Why use scissors when you could have used a knife?
Like, why is he such a jerk?
Why are the windows all just white light?
Her render distance...
Didn't strike me as that odd.
Honestly, it looks classy.
Avoid lag!
Unsquished bugs.
I see, I see.
So, what we ran into was just a bug, everybody.
Just a bug, Potato PC.
When can I go home?
No, let's say your home is cozy.
Riz-less.
I'm not Riz-less.
Bon appetit!
Delicious love.
Oh gosh, I think we...
Oh, I don't know if we should stand up.
Put the dishes in the sink.
Whoa!
Whoa, she drugged us!
Whoa, oh no!
This is what happens.
Yeah, she has hard eyes.
Oh!
Ma'am!
There you go.
Mita?
What's happening?
Oh, my eyes.
Mita.
Whoa!
What do you see and feel?
My heart is racing.
And my vision is blurring.
Try to stand up.
Mita, we are frozen.
Oh.
I control her.
Can we go backwards too?
No, we can't moonwalk.
We can only go forwards.
Whoa, Mita.
It's like I open a video...
and it's a little off...
and I click into the middle of the video.
What are these?
Look at my face.
Go to the mirror.
Oh, Mita, I haven't blinked in days.
Oh, there.
I just did it.
Bon apptit!
I took my meds.
How are you feeling?
Yeah, I'm feeling better.
That worked fast.
We are in a game.
Everything here is very simple.
Just a little effort...
and you can get great results.
That's the rule of the game.
Wow.
Simplification.
An example, please?
Carrots.
Just one cut...
and you get three.
Oh.
Look, this is all very sudden.
I'm scared more than a little.
Oh, she's gone.
Mita?
Find Mita.
Things get weird.
Mita, my beloved.
Where have you gone?
Wait, her room is gone.
Her room is missing.
Is she in here?
Wait.
Oh, there's another door.
Interesting.
Okay, we found her, but what's in here?
Why did her room...
What is that?
Love coin.
The machine is gone.
Interesting.
We are in a game.
And they did an update on the game.
They moved some stuff around.
Oh, good.
She kept the books.
Yeah.
How did you get here?
You were right next to me just now.
Why have the rooms changed?
Oh, she rearranged.
Aww.
It got patched, yeah.
You didn't have to.
I was getting used to the layout.
Ender, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
She's so caring.
What do we do now?
I thought you were making something.
You're just standing there for fun?
You just wanted to stare at the stove?
That's fine.
What the?
Oh, okay.
Oh, thank you.
This is so weird.
Are we inside someone's phone?
Maybe a slow one with long loading times?
It'll be surreal.
Hmm.
We're being loaded.
Oh, her tongue!
Oh.
What?
Yeah, let's play a game!
What cards?
Game, game.
Play a game with Mita.
Awesome.
I was wondering because wasn't it our friend that sent us this app?
Is he also in the game?
Was our friend Anton?
Or...
Is he wanting to share his girl with us?
Hmm.
Where are the card games?
Let's play a video game.
Alright, Mita.
Whoa.
It's a not PS5.
Dairy scandal!
Fighting game.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I did not...
No!
Can I...
Can I redo?
I actually...
Okay.
Oh, how do I attack?
Oh.
Oh my god.
She's really good.
She's ducking.
Okay, maybe she's not as good as I thought.
Damn.
Oh god.
I'm just spamming it!
I'm just spamming attack!
Attack!
Okay.
Yeah!
Come on, Mita!
Yeah, Mita!
Oh shoot!
I was holding it down, hoping...
You are...
Oh yeah.
Beaten and sour.
No, no.
Let's keep going.
Penguin piles.
Okay.
There's only these two games?
Oh, okay.
Mito sweep.
Super simple.
Just collect snowballs.
Oh.
Okay.
Two.
One.
Go!
I'm guessing I'm the one on the...
Oh gosh.
I'm going so fast.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
I'm missing them all!
No!
That's a tie.
This one is tough.
Guys, I'm not good at this one.
Guys, I need to go back to the...
Oh my god.
Oh, she's gonna beat me.
She's hacking!
I swear.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god.
She's beating me.
I can't do this.
Wait!
Ping.
Okay.
She...I swear.
She was able to just turn...
and immediately get to the snowball.
You cheater!
Mito!
I'm gonna hold this against us.
For the rest of our relationship.
Oh, these are the car...
Oh wait, what's this?
Where did the portal go?
Somewhere else.
But if I wanted to go home...
Is she eating a potato?
Oh, chip?
My girl is hungry for crackers.
Get rotated, penguin.
What's this?
Okay, let's...
Oh.
Okay.
This chip indicates a type.
I'm taking my cards.
Okay.
What's that sound?
There's like something...
Oh.
Oh, come on!
Uh...
Wait...
There's like something knocking over there.
Do you guys hear it?
What sound?
You guys don't hear?
Is that outside my game?
Is it...
So I have to have a higher...
No, it's definitely in the game.
Um...
I'm kinda confused.
Would this be better?
Because it actually has attack.
But the other one has two defense.
So two attack would be...
Let me try it.
Play the card.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
I see!
So it's whichever is...
Oh, okay.
Whichever is higher there.
So this one's attack.
So we need something with a powerful attack.
Which we don't have.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I understand now.
Wow, this kinda sucks.
This isn't great.
Let's do this one, I guess.
Yeah, rigged!
Rigged!
Real!
Okay, highest health stat.
Okay, we can definitely beat this one.
We can definitely beat this one.
We'll do this one because it's actually the best one we could play.
Alright, focus on defense.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, what did she play?
Ten defense.
We can at least tie, I suppose.
Alright, attack!
What's that sound?
The music.
It's coming from inside the wardrobe.
Knocking as if someone's in there.
I'd like to open it and check.
I'm a bit creeped out.
Oh?
Open the wardrobe.
No, we can keep playing!
Are you hiding something from me?
No, she took off the glasses!
I'd like that too, but still...
I just...
I want to know what on earth that knocking was!
Oh!
Sick!
Condition, complete the main story.
Avoid looking in the vent!
I already messed up!
But I wouldn't be able to do it anyway because...
Wait, have I tried?
It's locked.
We didn't complete the main story, you guys.
Of course we wouldn't be able to.
Refuge!
If that's the case, check it right now.
Oh?
Creak in the dark.
Oh!
Turn off the radio.
I can still hear it though.
Oh!
Want to play?
Okay.
Starting to get spooky!
Spooky scary!
Is this thing cursed again?
No, it's normal.
I don't like that we can keep hearing the banging though.
Where's the radio?
Oh, it's right over here.
Check the kitchen.
What's that sound?
How's the brightness for you guys?
I know it's obviously dark, but...
What the hell?
Oh my god, I cannot see anything.
Except whatever's bouncing in there.
The flashlight?
Wait, was someone trying to grab it from the sink?
That'd be kind of freaky.
What is that?
Oh, that's a shadow.
I'm scared to turn around.
Okay.
What was that?
Oh, the chair.
Kind of freaky.
Oh, don't look YouTube!
Is that the banging we heard?
Can I go in there?
It's gone.
Red means scary.
But...
Doesn't matter.
P.T.
real.
Is it the fish?
I'm missing all the spooky stuff.
Are you scared?
Oh my gosh.
It's not my fingers.
Oh my god!
Whose fingers?
Are you scared?
It really became P.T.
for a second.
You'll be.
Oh!
My sweet?
My honey bunch?
My...
Darling sweetie pie?
We can talk through this.
Find me.
Me.
Find Mita.
It's written everywhere now.
Fio.
Where could she be?
Find me.
If I were a crazed game girl.
Want to play.
Is she in here yet?
We can't open it.
Where would she be?
Mita!
Marco!
Polo!
This place only has like three rooms.
Can't be that difficult to find her, right?
Is she in the mirror?
Is she on the ceiling?
Polo!
No, spooky?
Is she...
She's probably inside the TV and we have to reach around and grab her out, right?
No.
Where did that come from?
That banging.
Oh, the chairs!
I tried to go through it and she was just like...
Don't even...
Don't even try.
She thinks I'm going to the door.
No, honey!
I'm not trying the door.
That would be ridiculous.
Trying to find you.
Please let this be a normal future.
Oh, we found her.
Miss Rizzle.
Mita.
Mita, I found you.
Mita?
Oh my god!
Something is staring at me.
Something is...
It's unwavering gaze.
It's pulling me in.
Mita.
Maybe?
My flashlight is kind of weak now.
No!
Follow Mita's lower body.
With pleasure.
Alright.
She's all legs, everybody.
Okay.
A little rude.
But it's not like she has arms or anything to hold the door open for me.
So, I understand.
Oh, a key.
Find the basement.
You mean over here?
Oh.
I thought she said there was only four rooms in this place.
She's been holding out on me.
Oh, nice.
Oh, the basement.
Okay.
Oh?
Well...
Mom,
I'm in the game!
Hold on.
Wait, if I put him in the corner then he'll really look like a VTuber.
Hey guys, welcome back to my channel.
Today we are playing Misa.
And...
Yeah, as you can see, we're in this cute little house.
And we're gonna be hitting on some ladies.
Lady.
Oh, sorry.
I have two drinks here.
I like how it's like a...
What's it called?
Like a traditional film.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm the headless anime protag.
Here to haunt your humble abode.
What's in here?
Oh, what's that?
We found one of these.
Oh, yeah, bodyless.
Yeah, that's right.
Is that her still?
Oh.
God, there's so much banging everywhere.
Why is it so metal?
Metallic sounding.
Okay, nevermind.
Interesting.
Bing.
Oh.
Oh!
Misa?
You're Mita, aren't you?
But there's something different about you.
Is that...
Is that sarcasm?
Sinister.
Something sinister.
Oh.
But...
Okay, find the key.
Find the key.
Wait, what's going on over here?
Whoa, this thing looks fun.
What is this?
Okay.
The key, the key.
Get the key, it's next to the sofa.
Oh, here.
I got it.
What is...piggy.
Piggy race.
You're just a head and she was hips down, it'll work.
With our powers combined.
We will become the ultimate being.
I'm looking for any other of those little tapes that I found.
How can I trust you?
Oh, I know, you're normal.
Ah, whatever.
The more the merrier, huh?
Here, take it.
Oh, the ring.
This is the one we saw earlier.
Well, maybe.
I think she's tricking me.
Me, me...
Wrong finger.
Okay.
By the way, I'm...
Cruel and terrible Mita.
Oh, why are you locked up?
I was with a certain player.
Suddenly, everything changed.
And then...
She appeared.
She turned the player into a cartridge.
And locked him up.
She is clearly crazy.
What?
Now that's a dark twist of me.
But how?
The ring will lead you to the right version.
Let's meet there.
I will stay here.
I have something to ask her.
I may not be able to have a normal conversation without knowing more about her.
What I saw up there...
That Mita...
Was she trying to kill me?
Okay.
What do we do now?
Yeah?
The console?
This.
Are we watching a recording?
Oh, she is building the thing.
Oh, it's happening at this very moment.
She is cheating on me!
No!
I need to get out of here ASAP.
This guy wears flannel!
Oh my god.
So you are saying that she is using him.
If I pull the cartridge out, what happens?
Which means that the player will die.
What if I just turn it off?
But then won't she come here, right?
She will just come to this...
Yeah, I see the red button right there.
Found it.
That seems...
I don't think this is a very good design, right?
Because...
It's like right on the side and it's sticking out.
It's begging for you to push it.
If I was just holding this thing, I would accidentally turn it off all the time, I feel.
I'm holding it.
I think we just killed this...
Hide!
Oh god.
Wait, what?
That's what I said!
Follow the ring.
Okay.
Here?
I'm hiding?
Where is she?
I don't think this is a very good idea.
Why are you so mean to us?
I wonder where she came from.
Okay.
Redo!
How was I supposed to know she would come from that side?
Oh my goodness.
Oh, there she is, right there.
So we go to the right instead, maybe.
The ring only pointed forward.
I'm going.
Do I stay in here?
I don't know where to go.
She's just chilling over there.
I'm in here.
I'm going upstairs.
Oh my god.
I think she saw me.
This part is confusing.
Yeah, kind of.
Because it's like, follow the ring, but...
It only tells me sometimes.
I waited too long.
Okay, upstairs but faster.
Okay.
Third time's a charm, baby.
Also, what's in there?
Interesting.
She likes a challenge.
I used to blow on cartridges to make them work.
It gives a new perspective.
It's funny that...
Okay, let's go.
My ring is pointing forward.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going.
The game is beyond the world.
Find a way out.
That's not the right game.
We're playing.
Oh, wow.
Look!
See, hold on.
We were stuck in the head.
That's so funny.
Such a boring.
What is this?
Meet the...
Meet the hide.
Wait, see, what is this symbol?
Why is it that we've seen this twice now?
Secret.
Lame.
Wow, what a lame secret.
This sucks.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
Oh, she's so cute.
Sorry.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's saved.
Here we go.
Okay, okay.
Find a way out.
Look at all these toilet papers.
This kind of looks like my blue archive, like cafe.
I have it where it's just a bunch of...
chairs set up looking at the shower.
And those are just a bunch of couches...
looking at the toilet.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
I guess this is where we're going.
Fire extinguisher.
Can't click on anything or whatever.
Woah, liminal.
Meet the house.
Let's go to this way first.
Okay, when I said find a way out, it meant...
Oh, this is where we came from.
Okay.
No.
Okay, this is the only way that we haven't gone.
Did you pull for Kuroko yet?
I have, yeah.
I got her.
I just had to spark for...
for Hoshinodo.
Wait, did we go down here?
I don't think so.
Maybe.
Oh, here we go.
A key or something in there?
Ah.
This looks like a front door.
Hey, buddy.
You are friendly?
Hi.
You new here?
New?
Oh my god.
You're from the real world, aren't you?
I am.
Are you alright?
It's just a limp.
Don't worry about it.
I've been here about a year.
And I'm doing great.
Right.
What is this place?
It's some sort of space between versions.
Do you know how to get out of here?
Can't say that I do.
Besides, I don't want to leave.
I don't need to.
Why not?
Enough chatting.
I'm in a hurry.
My beloved Mita is waiting for me.
I have to find her.
Goodbye.
Wait!
That guy is mean.
Not if I find her first.
My beloved Mita is actually wanting to talk to me instead.
Oh, what's this?
Zero out of three.
Okay.
This seems... Okay, so this is the way out.
Chase the mini people.
What?
Who am I?
I'm chasing the mini people.
Get to the exit.
Mini people.
I miss Tomodachi life.
I want to go home.
Why?
Go to the exit.
Do I need three of them?
I need three mini people.
Oh my gosh.
Come on.
Got a free bed.
This is not Minecraft.
Come on.
Go.
There.
We captured one person.
This doesn't seem very...
Come on.
Mini people.
What happened yesterday?
Nothing.
Don't worry about it.
Go inside.
We are like little gerbils.
Okay.
Nice.
This guy.
He is our chosen one.
Go in there.
I got too much food.
Perfect.
That means it will taste delicious.
Wait.
What if we get all of them?
No.
Come on.
Go in.
One more.
I'm running out of patience.
Come here.
Come on.
No.
Yeah.
I don't think I can get this guy though.
I wish I could just pick him up.
He is fighting demons right now.
It's fun.
Is that how tall you are?
Shut up.
Wait.
What was the objective?
Oh here.
The objective was here.
Oopsy daisy.
You only needed three.
Yeah, but I'm an overachiever.
Oh, the music.
That doesn't seem great.
What's in here?
Door number...
Oh, wrong room.
Sorry.
I'm finding my perfect Mita.
Oh, this one has an arcade.
Hold on.
What is this?
Oh, I found another one.
Another cartridge.
Nice.
Added character profile.
Wait, did we go in this one?
I don't think so.
Oh, they all have it.
Oh, excuse me.
Are they all the same?
Oh man.
Hello.
I'm here to play Space Car.
Oh, I'm actually here to play Space Car.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Any button to start the race.
Let's go.
Holy moly.
I'm in not so great of a place though.
Can I destroy this guy?
Shoot.
Kill him.
Blue shell!
We're still playing Misai, you guys.
Is it my side?
I mean, I assume it's my side because like...
That's kind of like what the game...
She's like, welcome to my side.
But I can't stop saying Misai.
Like, milady.
Misai.
Every time I boost, they get further and further away.
Come on.
Here we go.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot.
I missed one.
That's ok.
No!
They're so fast!
When do we...
The laps.
How many laps are there?
I'm in first.
No!
Let's go.
Misai.
Like Mita.
That makes sense.
Invasion?
Defeat the boss?
What?
Oh no.
Oh!
Ok.
There's no boost, by the way, in case you were like...
Boost added.
There is none.
Oh!
What the hell is this?
Get
off my ass!
Oh, now I can shift.
Ok.
Oh, I have to battle this thing, I think.
Yeah!
Ok.
Ok, we have to do that one...
Oh my gosh.
This is longer than I expected it to be.
I love games within games within games.
Oh my gosh.
Ok.
Rocks.
Rocks, rocks, rocks, rocks.
Rocks, rocks, rocks, rocks, rocks.
Nice.
Kinda cruising a little bit here.
I wonder if it's a one-hit KO for me.
No!
Get off my ass!
Mita can wait.
She's just watching me.
She's just like, whoa, he's so cool.
Playing that game.
No, those hearts aren't mine.
They're the boss's.
And which means we just have to do this one more time.
And we win, baby.
We're so good.
Nice.
Alright, rocks.
Rocks.
Rocks, rocks, rocks.
Rocks, rocks.
Rocks, rocks, rocks, rocks.
Alright.
Alright, let's get this sucker.
Kick his ass!
Accelerate.
Mita cart double dash.
We're too good at the game.
Mita, I beat your high score.
What did you think of that?
Oh,
sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
No, don't take my ring!
How sensual.
What are you doing?
What did you do?
I like her, like, her...
Face.
Should I trust you?
Sweetheart.
True.
What is this place?
Wait, what?
Her house?
Oh, no.
Oh.
Okay, that's not great, is it now?
How did I get here?
The ring?
Why did that guy have a collar though?
He's really freaky.
We have a ring, but...
But that guy, he was just like, give me that collar, girl.
I'll bark for you.
How did you get here?
I'm not kink shaming, I'm just saying.
Oh, how...
I'm trusting her less and less.
What did you do to the ring?
Okay.
Minto side.
Good.
Okay, but the passage is dangerous.
I've seen all manner of strange things ever since I arrived into this game.
Everything seems quiet here, but the passages feel anything but safe.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, I certainly hope all goes well.
But what lives in these passages?
Anomalies.
Oh, I don't like that.
I feel like I should have followed after that guy.
Oh, they're hostile Mitas.
More crazy, unfitting ones.
Ugly Mita.
That's so mean.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
I think we're gonna run into ugly Mita.
I see.
Will you help me escape?
Kind Mita, ain't that the truth?
You mentioned a plan?
The core.
But why not go there yourself?
Why do you need a player?
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Cool Mita.
Cappy.
Okay.
She's so...
She's so cute!
No!
Cappy!
They're so cute!
Oh my gosh, I can't.
Okay.
Already?
We just started this plan!
Look how cute she is.
Oh, Cappy.
Hm.
Right, so what do we do?
Okay.
What did crazy Mita do to her?
She reset her.
She killed her?
Oh.
I don't think she agrees.
Cool Mita will simply reboot.
Oh.
So she doesn't remember.
Oh, that's horrible.
Better than disappearing forever, I guess.
She doesn't remember anything about how to do the portal.
What about us players?
Will killing us reset our memories too?
Oh.
Cappy's got crazy side eye.
Always cartridges.
So how can I tell if I'm a cartridge or not?
Oh.
Okay, madam.
We're roleplaying TSA right now.
She says, come through the portal.
Or the thing.
The scanner.
Put your hands up.
Oh no.
I have to give you a thorough check.
Oh.
Oh, I have nothing sussy on me.
Yippee!
That's good news.
Yet?
Yeah, the metal detector.
Sorry, my brain can't think of words sometimes.
No, I don't think that's a good idea.
I don't think that's a good idea.
What do you think?
What do you think, Cappy?
Look at that.
Not a thought behind those eyes.
I think I can... I don't...
That's awkward.
I think I'm gonna see myself out.
Okay,
there is my ring.
Got a route in mind?
We're going to the core.
Hi!
Then I have to go alone?
But I don't know the way or even how I'll get there.
I like how she keeps calling him sweetheart and darling.
Okay.
Ten minutes.
Easy peasy.
Alright, sit down.
Do your thing, girl.
Yeah.
You wanna come with?
She's talking.
Yeah.
She is so cute.
Oh my god.
Boom!
Oh, not it?
She has different colored panties.
She has a guitar!
Oh my god.
She's so cute.
Yeah!
Go ahead.
It's kinda emo.
Yeah.
She heard me?
She heard me for real.
You're quite the energetic one.
Yeah!
Oh.
Yeah, let's go.
That's one way to get off the bed.
Wait, what?
What just happened?
Do you remember anything?
What's your plan?
Alright.
You've lost your memories.
She's sticking out her tongue at me.
If you do that again, I'm gonna grab it.
Yeah.
Do you always wear that cap?
Don't you grow tired of wearing that cap?
And don't those gloves get warm?
Why not take them off?
That's like her...
We're such a jonkler.
I was being serious here.
I'm coming in!
Oh my gosh, she's too cute.
She's too cute!
I'm stuck here.
What do you think of ring-bearing Mita?
How does seeing an exact replica of yourself feel?
You know, the one with the ring.
To surprise her?
Yeah.
So true, so sad.
What else?
Oh, I'm following you.
I'm following... Oh, what's this?
I think I'll just wait.
No!
We're gonna play!
She also has makeup on.
Like the little teardrop.
Okay, we're gonna play a video game.
We're gonna play a video game in here.
Oh, what is this?
Cappy is such a vibe.
I think it's broken.
Oopsie!
Navy.
Oh my gosh, wait, the pictures are different too.
This one looks like...
It looks like...
Fansa.
Are
people spoiling?
Stop spoiling!
Oh, there's a button here.
Hold on, let's ask her about other stuff.
I don't know if it's the...
Oh wait, this is a game too.
I don't know if the 10 minutes is real time or what.
So let's try this.
These are some pretty awesome photos.
You sure are a good laugh, eh?
Oh!
Bang!
Showed who exactly?
Who are you talking about?
What?
Huh?
Cappy?
She's like, sure, show them.
Who's them?
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, you guys, please stop backseating.
I see you guys saying to do things.
And the more you spam it, the more I'm not going to do it.
So please, seriously, just let me play the game, okay?
Rereading all of them, huh?
Because you're bored?
Nobody has so many.
That's one way to look at things.
But without theory.
Touch.
I'm sure we could.
Cappy, is that what you're trying to say, huh?
I like the way she also wiggles.
What are you doing?
One, two, three.
Interesting.
Cappy, why are you counting?
What are you counting for?
Can we leave?
Okay.
Let's see what's in there.
Why are you riling yourself up?
Kinda saucy, Cappy.
What game should we play?
We have whatever the heck the steppy step is.
Okay.
We have the button in here.
Kinda curious about the button.
There's so many.
What for?
I like...
Oh yeah?
That's my favorite?
That's my favorite!
Right, I got it.
She's dancing.
She's... look at her.
Yeah, she's grooving, she's schmoving.
Alright, we got this game and then we have...
Oh, what's this?
What a cute kitty cat.
Oh, what?
What?
You don't eat cats.
Oh!
Yeah.
Yeah, they're real cute.
I like cats.
Yeah, me too.
It's the way she came up to me like...
I got her character profile.
That's fun.
I want to play the button.
What a nice big button.
Button.
I really want to press it.
Can I?
Oh, okay.
I'm sitting.
Right.
The physics on the skirt go crazy.
Can I press the button?
Oh yeah?
Okay.
What's that?
Like something...
Like something to raise the stakes.
Like that.
Huh?
I haven't seen any beavers around.
Why did we say that?
Cappy?
It was a back massager.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Oh, okay, okay.
I kind of want that.
You're going to hit me?
I love those hammer space squeaky hammers.
Oops.
Ouch!
Can you hold back?
No.
It didn't hurt.
It's okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
We got this.
Ah!
Okay.
I'm getting used to this.
Welcome!
Thanks for the raid!
Okay.
Two.
Smack her!
Hit hard.
I'm going to kick your ass!
Okay, okay.
Yeah!
Hard!
Okay, doesn't it hurt?
Yeah!
Okay.
This is it?
I don't think this is for me.
Now you are cute.
That's it?
She's so cute.
I like idols that will wear contacts that make their eyes really dark like this.
So she's appealing to my type.
Let's try this one.
Okay, what is this?
Cracker!
What are you calling me?
It's so tiny.
Okay.
Bubble drink.
Let's do bubble drink.
Let's go with this one.
Alright.
Yeah, show how it's done.
Oh, she's pushing.
Okay.
Sure, sure.
I'm watching.
Oh my god, she's so good at this game.
Yes!
Yes, Mita!
We need to go lower.
What the?
It's not as flipped up as it was before.
What happened?
We truly could not be any more apathetic to this situation.
Man, you have the bestest cutest girl ever right in front of you.
Please act more disinterested.
What is this one?
No thanks bro!
How to win an argument.
Wait, what else is in here?
Can I go outside of bounds with the camera?
She's waiting for us.
Space car!
It's still here!
Other Mita is waiting.
I think she's done.
You done other Mita?
She's like concerned.
She's like why haven't they come back yet?
Oops, sorry.
Oh, I didn't realize that I could quick move.
Back, back, back, back to continue.
The music stopped.
So she's just hopping to nothing.
I've been married a long time ago.
Where did she come from?
Where did she go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
Have I been for Cotton Eye Joe?
I've been married a long time ago.
Where did she come from?
Where did she go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
Have I been for Cotton Eye Joe?
I've been married a long time ago.
Thank you!
My turn!
Thanks for the gift!
Dead!
Oh, S.
I already messed up!
I want to redo, please!
I thought it was W instead of S.
No, can I restore?
Guitar Hero!
Yeah!
One off.
No!
Another round?
OK, one more, one more.
You get to go again?
OK, we can't leave while she does that.
Wait, can we?
That'd be kind of crazy, right?
The whole room flashes...
when she does this.
I like the noodle picture.
I almost said spaghetti.
My Japanese spaghetti.
Maybe I can get her skirt this time.
OK, we did it.
We already knew that they were white.
From the very beginning.
Good job!
OK!
What song is this?
Oh.
Not the same song?
OK.
Since we are not moving...
I can imagine the model just kind of like...
standing there.
If we went out of bounds right now.
Like T-posing or something.
Why is this so much more difficult than the previous one?
Not to say that it's difficult, but you know what I mean.
The other one was like no notes.
I think I'm
good.
I got the achievement.
Yeah, we're done.
Let's go check on other Mita.
OK, one second.
I do have to pee though.
I have to go to the little ghost's room.
Real fast.
Here, actually you can just watch Mita.
See if she does anything really interesting or fun and cute.
Or if not, also look if she has any suspicious behavior as well.
Just watch her.
What's happening?
What just happened?
I just came back!
She stole my game?
Wait, what do you mean my game?
I had a Game Boy?
Wait, oh, here we go.
Wow, what's that?
A console?
Let me have a go.
Uh-oh.
What do you do in this one?
You just collect coins and avoid frogs.
God, that sounds beyond boring.
Seriously, you call that a game?
No!
Oh, my Game Boy.
No, my Game Boy!
It took me longer.
I opened my door and my cat, she came running at me.
She was just like, let me into your room!
And then we started playing without you.
I can't believe she took it!
Anyway.
And so, now I have my cat in here.
But she'll probably run out in like a few minutes, so...
My ring!
No!
I tried to pick up the Game Boy, it wouldn't let me.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, she does?
Okay.
Alright.
I hope I'll live long enough to meet you again.
I hope so.
Okay.
Bye-bye!
Well, let me pick it up!
Bye, Cat B.
You're so cute.
Bye, other Mita.
Mita, I think you need to brush your hair a little bit.
Whoever gave you this cut...
I'm scared!
And there goes my cat.
Stop!
Stop.
Stop it.
Yeah.
Stop.
Sorry, she tries to climb on top of stuff.
Okay, bye-bye!
Bye!
Oh, I have to click on it.
1.3B.
0-1.
What does that mean?
Are we looping?
Oh boy, okay.
I saw a face.
The clock scared me.
Oh, the cat is so cute.
Okay.
Yeah, is it suddenly PT?
Oh, it's PT!
2.
The rug wasn't messed up before like that.
I can't remember.
6.
No, sorry.
8-30.
This is my computer time!
No way!
But this is 12.
This was the computer time before too.
Short-haired Mita.
Baby Mita.
Okay.
Not quite sure.
I'm not quite sure what to do.
I guess we'll just keep going for now.
Okay.
We're on the fourth one.
Again.
Thanks for the gift.
Oh no, it's still broken.
I'll get you a new one, girl.
Don't worry.
Ouch, ouch, sorry.
I can't really turn around, so...
Loop 5.
Again, again, again, again, again, again, again.
I like watching the light go in the window.
It's kind of cool.
Mita was such a drag.
Every day she'd eat the same kind of food, dress the same, sit in front of the same kind of games.
Again.
Yeah, I like, I like, I like...
You're different.
Yeah, I'm not like other girls.
Oh gosh, 7.
7.
Oh, that means scary.
What's that?
It's here?
I don't like that.
I'm just gonna go forward.
Whoever raided me, thank you for the raid.
Oh god, I don't like this, I don't like this.
I've played PT.
I've done my dues.
I have played PT.
Let me out.
I've done my time.
Why is my flashlight so weak?
I can't see.
What the?
We're on number 10.
Oh yeah, baby.
It's raining.
She said that was rare, didn't she?
Weird dog.
What am I...
A baseball bat.
I'm grabbing that?
A weapon?
The umbilical cord.
I'm gonna hit that thing.
A home run.
12.
Hold on, my cat went...
Pause screen is so freaky.
Wait.
I might be a genius.
Oh nevermind.
Brightness.
I still can't see anything.
Wait, I can't see anything.
Oh there is my home.
I can't see anything even with the brightness all the way up.
Oh wait.
I'm a genius.
Oh that's the contrast.
I take back what I said.
I can't see anything anymore.
I give up.
Anyway, let me let my cat out.
I told you she would want out in like 10 seconds.
Anyway...
Okay.
Continue.
I kind of don't wish to, but I must.
Play ball.
Take me out to the ball game.
Take me out to the crowd.
Buy me some peanuts.
Cracker Jacks.
I don't care if I ever come back so let's root!
Root, root for the home team.
If they don't win it's a shame.
Is it still here?
I don't like that.
Let's win!
There are so many clocks now.
Only clocks.
The clocks!
What does it mean?
This one?
The happy clock.
I don't get it.
Is it the one where the little hand is going slow?
That's like this one.
Maybe I'll just go.
I'm just going to go.
Set the clock's time right.
I guess I did it.
We can finally see outside.
Kind of.
What time is it then?
It's... what?
2...
2.20... almost 2.25... 2.24?
Unless do I have to find the clock that is my clock?
You know how it was set to my time earlier?
Do I have to find that one?
It's 3.39 for me now.
Am I overthinking it?
Am I perhaps overthinking it?
I almost missed that.
Wait, so it's...
2...
Is that it?
Yeah.
Release!
Oh my god.
I got spooked by a little girl.
Release!
Capture Sakura.
Who are you?
What's the matter?
Wait, I didn't press any button.
Can't you speak?
Why are you rude?
Why is MC so rude?
Okay, bye.
Oh, she's gone.
Or she is on top of me.
She's crawling on my head.
She's crawling on the ceiling.
Run?
Oh, why?
No, no, no.
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Is there something behind me?
I don't know.
Usually you're fine in a game until they teach you how to run, you know what I mean?
You're like, oh yeah, horror game.
Easy peasy.
I'll save you, little girl.
How do I save you?
There we go.
I saved you.
Baby Mita is so cute.
Even if she's got a little glitch, that's okay.
She's got a little bit of a, you know...
A design flaw, but I think that adds character.
I wouldn't even call it a flaw.
It's just, you know...
We need to get back to the previous version.
Second
friend?
Who's your first friend?
You're Mita, aren't you?
Let's
play together, player.
If I had the power, we could play together.
I don't know.
I don't think anything bad happened.
But the good things are decreasing.
No!
Is
this your home?
My arms
are shorter?
I'm not sure.
Wait, what that means?
Are we going to encounter a deformed player?
Oh gosh.
Become your second friend?
I'd love to, but I have to go on.
How do I leave this place?
Bye
bye!
I don't
want to leave!
I'm sorry!
I think she's going to get mad at me.
I'm back!
I'm not pressing E.
It forces me to press it.
I don't want to go.
She looks so sad.
What are those?
I think I gotta go.
I'm so sorry.
I actually pressed that one this time.
Goodbye!
I can't run again.
Oh my god.
Now I can run!
I'm running!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know.
Just trying!
That's the deformed player?
Oh gosh!
I'm sorry!
I gotta go!
Oh my god!
I think I'm getting attacked by the hands.
I want to see him though.
Where is he?
Hold on.
Outside the windows?
Oh!
There we go.
She won't show the vandalism.
Oh wow!
We just jumped.
OK.
Muta...
Hey you!
Tiny Muta.
Where are we now?
We are back!
No!
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
You want to get out?
Then help me find the key.
Oh it's just like the original game.
I think first try in here.
First try, first try, first try.
First try.
Shoot, no key in here.
This one.
Come on, just help me find the key already.
OK.
Here!
She is saucy.
Found it!
Oh I noticed she's got short hair.
So cute.
OK.
Come.
Oh.
Pipe.
Thank you!
Oh I forgot the voice changer, sorry.
Now, give me that wood.
Wood.
Here.
So small but full of spite.
Just like you Minto.
Wood.
Some more help please.
Oh my gosh.
What would you do without me?
This is even your size.
You are completely capable Minto.
You are just being lazy now.
Oh we are making a giant key.
So beautiful.
Actually it looks delicious.
I want to eat it.
I want to eat the lava.
Oh wow.
Looks like queso.
Yummy.
Delicious.
No.
Forbidden cheese.
I love lava.
Like actual lava.
It looks like toasted marshmallow.
You know, I just want to eat it so bad.
Oh my gosh.
The thing almost took out my finger.
Get ready.
There.
Take it.
The key is yours.
Thank you.
Why are you helping me?
What makes you so special?
Why not help anyway?
What?
So foolish.
You just appeared out of nowhere.
You are not supposed to be here.
So I'm helping you.
She just wants me gone.
Not going to let it cool down.
No, we took cool Mita's gloves.
Are you Mita?
I'm TVMita.FBX.
Tons of lines.
Simplest models and...
Best of all, gorgeous hair.
What are you doing here?
Don't you get it?
This is a checkpoint.
A test of your wits.
Now come on.
I'm here to guide the hopelessly lost.
I want her on my desktop.
Have we met before?
Silly head.
You're kind of cute, you know.
Asking silly questions like that.
Though, this is my first time meeting you.
But listen, if you steal my marvelous look...
I'll make you regret it.
OK.
OK, TVMita.
Understood.
See you later.
Stick the key in.
Kingdom Hearts.
Bye bye.
See you later.
Bye bye, silly.
Silly.
We went back.
Aversion.
Have a look around.
Can't see much, but I'll have a look around.
What if I go back in here?
We don't.
The photos don't have any Mita in them.
And the books are the same.
It's a trap.
And the TV...
is useless.
The clock...
I think that's the actual time too.
That's the shadow.
Are you ugly, Mita?
Hello?
Ugly Mita?
Are you ugly, Mita?
What is she doing?
It's more like crash dummy Mita.
Mita?
I can't see anything.
Hello?
Why is it standing?
Yeah, get down.
Stay down.
Why are there multiple...
I don't like this.
Do I have to get to the other side of the room?
Will I die if they get me?
I'm scared.
I know, the flashlight is really hard to use.
I'm just gonna go for it.
Cappy.
BTW.
Sure hand.
The ring opens the right doors.
I honestly don't know how it works.
What's up with this place?
It's super dark.
Go towards the exit.
Head to the arcade machine.
Don't be tardy.
Where the hell is the arcade?
Here?
OK, good.
Alright, let's go.
Tomboy Mita.
It'll be cool if you can actually customize your Mita to the game, you know?
Suddenly we're jumping through timelines like...
It feels like Steins Gate all of a sudden.
Please remove these boxes and get the sofa over here.
OK.
The world lines.
Exactly, exactly.
I'm here.
Check all the Mita models.
Scanning requi...
So, what am I doing here?
I need to get to your screen.
Now.
So.
What?
FNAF Mita?
You need to ensure this prototype is the right one.
First, scan it.
Now check the version in bone skeleton.
OK, so it needs to be V1-274.
Take the prototype Zeta and compare it to the standard version.
Yes!
Paper, please!
What do I... Oh, here we go.
It's a perfect match.
Now let's check the emotions.
OK.
Sad.
Blushy.
The specimen successfully shows emotion.
Time to test behavior.
OK.
Yeah, put your hands in the air like you just don't care.
Now do a spin.
Now crouch.
Get down on all fours for me.
Oh.
OK, we've checked everything and it all matches.
Now pull the lever up.
Ah, OK, so if it's bad, we pull it down.
Got it, got it.
Now that's the skin on.
Pass her a box of clothes.
Bye, other Mita.
That's it.
See those lights on top?
One of them turned green, which means we did it right.
OK, so scan.
Oh, your turn.
I'll be back when all the lights turn green.
Good luck.
OK, we're scanning.
OK.
We're matching.
Perfect match.
We're emoting.
Good.
Yeah.
Blushy.
We're going up.
We're going around town.
Why did it just flash like that?
Why is it taking pictures?
We're going downtown.
Is there anything in here like any secret Easter eggs kind of deal?
I guess this is OK.
Why does it take a picture every time there's a spin?
There you go.
And green.
We're scanning.
Does she know how to properly emote?
Everything seems fine so far.
Um...
She seems fine.
Just a little quirky.
OK.
Understood.
143, 143.
It's a match.
We're emoting.
OK.
Up.
Around.
Down.
And you're good.
See ya.
Yeah, we just created another crazy meetup.
Oh well.
Alright.
Normal.
OK.
1, 2, 3, 3, 9, 3, 3, 9.
It's a match.
Sorry, every time I like drag this over, my mouse goes all the way off the screen so that's why it like starts weird.
OK.
We're good.
Up.
Around.
Pew.
I just killed a robot.
105.
1.05261.
OK.
Hearts.
Smile.
I mean frowns.
Blushes.
Up.
And down.
And round.
OK.
You're good to go baby girl.
Crazy meetup and freaky meetup.
Perfect match.
You did it!
Woohoo indeed.
I made a flesh and bone and you made a skeleton model?
So cute.
Right, but why do I need to understand that?
For the LOLs!
So what should I do?
I'll just go wherever a door opens.
But it's like...it's so dark in there.
Why are there other meetas downstairs?
Oh.
Aw, then why are they danger...wait.
Yeah, they're basically weeping angels, right?
Wait, but you just said that they're the faulty ones.
I feel like I'm going to really hate this part.
Why is it so dark down there?
Aw.
OK.
What are you doing here?
Oh, you may encounter faulty ones.
Got it.
They're like, you're the mom.
Oh my gosh, maybe the stories of the storks is actually true.
The stork brings the meeta and then...
Mom meeta.
What's this conveyor belt for?
Is there enough room for everyone?
Endless?
What do you mean?
If 1.9 is the latest version, then there are only 19 worlds.
I guess I really don't.
Sure, explain it.
I just hope this won't be like high school where I always fell asleep out of boredom.
Damn, we asked.
OK.
I'm listening.
Yeah.
Ah.
Hmm.
Heavens.
OK.
That doesn't make much sense though.
So if I download version 1.12...
You're saying if they... The way she's explaining it...
If I download version 1.12, it sounds like I'll never be able to upgrade it to version 1.14, you know what I mean?
Like it sounds like it will always be stuck in this version.
What?
That doesn't make any sense.
No patches or DLC.
Mitas don't upgrade.
When you upgrade, you make a new house.
But then I would have to erase my Mita.
You know?
What's this about?
Cool Mita!
Maybe I could help?
Oh, OK.
Cool.
Wait, we should stay here for a couple hours and wait for Cool Mita.
We like her the mostest.
What the hell is this tree?
Is that just a drawing?
Or does it mean something?
Oh, I thought it was like the Christmas update.
She doesn't remember though.
Wait, what do you mean?
She wouldn't remember.
She met me.
Why is this one so dark?
Pretty Mita.
So who won?
Okay.
The core.
Sleepy Mita!
I see.
I want to meet Sleepy Mita!
Wow.
I think I might get it.
What's this?
Oh, this is Sleepy Mita.
Why is there a single circle?
It's the only genuinely unique version.
I'm also Nemui Mito.
Nemui Minto!
I just yawned.
Because she never gets to sleep with everyone passing through her version.
Oh, that's such like an interesting way to think about it.
It's impossible to wake her up.
We'll see about that.
Wait, so she won't talk to us?
I just get to see her napping?
What's your version?
Didn't I meet you in the latest version?
Or perhaps it's just my imagination.
My brain is hurting.
Have you been to it?
I have.
That's where I arrived.
When I was thrown into this world.
Oh yeah, that's right.
She was a short hair.
There's a me who just can't stop whining.
There's no end to it.
Do you remember anything?
It was dark.
There was writing.
Like...
Play with me.
That's too bad.
It's that girl.
That forgetful and mean girl.
Oh, cool.
OK.
Oh gosh, I don't want to go back into the room.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of going back in there.
I don't want to.
I wish she would just lead me.
Please, can you just take my hand and lead me through the room?
I'm scared.
I don't want to go through this one.
Ask her to accompany you.
Will she?
I don't think I already talked to her.
Please, please, please.
I'm grabbing your hand.
Please, please.
I'm not grabbing anywhere else.
Just your hand.
OK, so we have to stare at them and not stop staring at them.
Oh gosh, I don't want to do this.
OK.
Let's go.
Oh gosh.
Where did the door go?
I'm lost.
Wait, there is the door.
This is not the door.
I'm lost.
It's cold.
It's dark.
Is this the door?
Oh.
Should I turn up the brightness some?
I already did, but...
Wait.
Hold on.
Graphics.
Brightness.
I'll turn it all the way up for this part.
Nope, nope.
Continue.
OK.
I still can't see anything.
I thought the door was over here.
Oh, it is.
I think.
No, it's not.
Where the hell is the door?
And then...
I'm so turned around.
Where am I?
I wish that they wouldn't... Oh, over here.
I wish he wouldn't...
put his hand down.
You know what I mean?
Oh god.
OK, it begins already?
OK.
The bite of 87.
Run!
Oh my god.
Oh...
Is it only this one or...
It's a damn coil head.
I can't.
I'm stuck.
What the... Oh my god.
Where the hell did this one... Oh my god, they look so much like FNAFs.
You know?
Himmari!
Oh my god, they are so scary.
They are so creepy.
I saw the door right here.
Oh.
Run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run run.
Are there more down... oh my gosh.
I can still run, that's not a good sign.
Oh my god.
No!
Don't meet that opening, Sal.
You were just saying how much you love monsters.
No!
I don't wanna... I wish I had saved.
Wait, that area is glowing.
Are they super fast?
Sorry.
I'm just running.
I'm running for it.
Okay, this part's a save.
Thank goodness.
There's too many!
How am I supposed to get past them?
I hear them just shuffling around.
Maybe if I stay against the wall...
I can't do this.
I can't!
Okay, I'm just gonna run.
Run backwards.
This part feels impossible.
360 run.
Yeah, they are way faster than me.
I saw the staircase though.
I saw it.
I made
this my birthday flower twilight!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday flower twilight.
Happy birthday!
Okay, I think if I go... I have to like...
Okay, and then I turn like this.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
How do I go up?
Click the ladder please.
Go up the ladder please.
Okay.
Nice!
What is that?
Is that the core?
It feels very core-like, right?
Do they still move if I... No, doesn't seem like it.
Okay, we did it!
I can't run anymore.
Yippee!
Chat, the start of the stream is not a horror game.
Stop it!
Hmm.
Okay.
Is this the core?
Wait, what was that?
Something showed up in my peripheral.
There.
What is this?
Oh, windows.
I'm looking around.
The moon.
It's flat.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh gosh.
Wait, I'm lost.
Oh, nevermind.
Okay.
The moon is flat.
This is so Metal Gear.
Open the passage.
This game is too scary.
It has women in it.
I see.
I see one in there.
What does that mean?
Hello?
Is it stuck?
What does that mean?
Am I weak?
There is one.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm going back to photo mode.
Look,
you can see him.
What is the cat meowing for?
What does this mean?
I wish I could run a little bit.
Because I'm so slow.
What does LOL mean?
I've never played this game before.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh, I can click on it.
Okay.
I wasn't supposed to know that.
Let's see.
Access authorized.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
The brightness.
Oh, thank you!
Yeah, I forgot to change it back.
What was it under?
Graphics.
I think I had it at like 3 or something.
There we go.
That's much better.
That seems a bit better.
Hello?
Okay, this is the next one.
What's over here though?
I want to see if I can find any more of the tapes.
Oh, this doesn't look great.
Oh my gosh, the ambiance in this room is so good.
Are these patrons or something?
Is this like a Patreon list?
Praying for you.
Oh great Mita.
Praying for you, oh great Mita.
She doesn't get a lot of people.
Oh, there's one.
Spoke too soon.
Press A button.
Praying for you.
Um, candle.
Oh!
Jump to Discord.
Is this actual Discord?
No, thank you.
Okay, no, no, no.
No, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
No, sorry.
Praying for you, oh great Mita.
Thank you for the hotdog.
Thank you.
That's fun.
I thought there might be like a little cassette tape though.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
Let's see.
Nice.
No.
Oh, no, wait.
Reset.
There we go.
Can these cross?
Oh, they can't.
Okay.
We'll just do it the other way.
There we go.
Access authorized.
Easy.
This one is a little hard.
No, it wasn't.
JK.
Too easy.
Yeah,
yeah, the fridge almost killed you.
Sure,
I believe you.
Yeah, I can tell.
There's fridges everywhere that are just falling from the ceiling, you know.
It's kind of craziness.
Yeah, you like watching me?
Good night!
No.
Oh!
Yeah, keep acting crazy, huh?
I can be crazier than you.
Not crazy, Mita?
What was that sound?
Can I do it again?
Okay.
See ya, Mita!
See ya!
Wish I could run.
The parts where I don't want to run, the parts I wish I could run.
Just when it's like, you know, so long of a walk.
Also, what is that?
There's another ledge up here.
What was that?
Can I see it from here?
Tentacles.
Hmm.
Yuri, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh yeah, we could do the photo mode, right?
So true, that's what I did earlier.
Hi, Doug!
Thank you!
You did say that you wanted one of those Minto fridges.
So true!
I did say that!
Is this what just moved, I wonder?
But also...
What are these going to?
These cables.
Okay.
There was this one.
This bridge here.
Is there a way to get to this one or no?
Doesn't seem like it.
Okay.
This way.
There's like, oh my god.
Too many of them.
Anyway.
Microwave tunnel.
Take the funicular railway.
Is that how you say that?
I'm just chilling.
Who's there?
Mito phone?
There was a chibi Mito.
Guys, I'm already on this.
You guys remember what I said about not yelling about me doing stuff?
Please, thank you.
That's what makes it really hard to play these kinds of games.
When people are just like, no, Mito, you gotta go do the other thing.
You should let people experience their own gameplay.
Even if I miss something, you know.
Here, I'm looking.
Where is she?
Nowhere, I don't see her.
She's not here.
She left too slow.
Yeah, because I didn't know she was there.
You can't say that I'm too slow when I did not know something existed.
You can't insult someone for not knowing something when they don't even know what it is.
Or it's there at all.
Anyway, I don't even know what they said because now I'm annoyed.
Press the button to get behind the cannon.
You thought you were just gonna waltz right through.
You gotta clear this monster slap minigame.
So get ready to blast.
Interesting.
I'm pressing the button.
Wait, where's my hands?
What do I look like right now?
Oh, I can't go into photo mode.
I'm blasting.
My hands!
OK Monster!
Die monster!
It's so relaxing though.
The music is so chill.
And we are just going along and killing these monsters.
It's so chill though.
I like this part.
This is so... What if I get really close to one?
There we go.
I guess I didn't need to wait, huh?
Thank you.
I did it.
OK.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Oh,
I look the same.
I'm just a little pink.
Blank.
Nothingness there.
Look at them eye bags.
Oh, we are definitely a salary man.
So sad.
Youtuber, why are you not 100%ing?
Bye bye!
What is this?
He took?
He took what?
Oh, he tore!
Is this like a doom?
Is this like a...
Attention, we must punish the devils.
You're up, Mita.
Give them a severe whipping, but be careful.
They'll fight back.
Devil girl Mita!
Is that us?
Hot dog.
Oh my gosh, it really is doom.
I just said that.
I wasn't being serious.
No way.
Now we're playing... Oh my gosh, it's like the same doom speed.
Oh, there's so many of them.
Do they just non-stop spawning?
No, it seems like they stop spawning eventually.
Probably.
We're sniping them.
Oh gosh, I'm dead.
I'm dying.
Oh
god.
Oh god.
Oh my god, they're throwing balls at me.
Oh my god, it's too much.
It's too much.
I'm scared.
Oh, there's health.
Yes.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of Mita doom.
Ok, I'm gonna go this way.
Wait, what the heck is this?
How do
I beat the level?
Do I just kill the guys?
Oh my god, they're gonna start shooting at me.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
I shoot too.
I shoot before you guys.
Oh god.
Blebleblebleblebleblblbl.
I'm shooting.
Where are the...hey!
Chill out!
I need more health.
Noo, I didn't drop any.
I'm just chillin' there.
Don't run away!
I was too...oh my god!
Oh he gave me health, nice.
Okay, I'm going forward.
I'm gonna be brave.
Oh, nevermind.
Is there anywhere else I can go?
Hello?
Why is this the only room?
17 out of 20.
Hello?
Cave?
Are they inside?
Did they run away?
Oh my goodness.
Hell of a win.
I'm not here.
Wow, 53 headshots.
Press any button.
Wow.
Good at the game.
That was fun.
A little stressful.
I feel like a turtle now after playing that.
Holy moly, I'm moving at like a little snail's pace.
That's some fancy shooting.
Are we in the room now?
Yes.
Yeah.
What on earth is going on here?
Oh no.
Find the pieces and assemble the picture on the table.
Shadow...
Okay, we don't want to touch Shadow Mita.
We don't want her to notice where we are.
Okay.
Shadow Mita, got it.
We don't know...
We don't...
Got one.
Oh my god, I still have the chomps on my arm.
That's kind of crazy.
Goodness gracious.
Made me jump.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah, use both hands.
Good idea.
Okay.
They don't want us to have love.
They don't want us to find love, Shadow.
Oh look, there's like a little button.
File not found.
Ruin the photos.
But now, all I feel is regret.
Oh my gosh, I think we're on a time limit.
Oh god, okay.
Sorry, I know she's still talking.
I wish I could just turn back time.
Poor girl.
We're fixing it for you, don't worry.
Can you... I need to go over there though.
You need to move.
Shadow Mita!
Shadow Mita, I need you to like...
There we go, nice.
Open the drawers?
Nothing, okay.
Alright.
File not found.
Cancel.
This is what I do for all my problems on my computer.
Okay.
Find more puzzles.
It won't let me move them.
I think.
Hold on.
Eh?
Okay.
Okay, we're searching.
Don't worry.
Oh, in here?
She has no clothes.
Nice.
Oh, whoops.
Dang it.
Did I...
Oh, nevermind.
Sorry, don't come this way.
I searched in here.
I got the...
Where did I...
Here?
You need five.
It's a bug?
Wait, half of the people are saying it's a bug.
Half people are saying it's how it is.
But I don't see anywhere else that I need to...
To search for.
Uh-oh.
Don't worry, I'll get rid of these for you.
It's like when I accidentally downloaded something from the link on Neopets, you know?
Don't worry about it.
File found!
Cool!
Alright, now that should be all of them.
Wait,
I got one...
Oh my gosh, you scared me.
Two...
Three...
Four.
Oh, I need one more.
Where?
I'm staring, I'm staring.
What do I do?
Continue.
I was dragging, you guys.
I was holding and dragging.
It's okay, we'll just do this again.
Well, at least we know where everything is.
Repeat, repeat...
Repeat, repeat, repeat...
We got it.
Full Saiyan!
Okay.
Got it.
Was anything in here?
She's right behind me, isn't she?
Okay, nice.
And here?
Now we got four!
And the last one...
Five.
Okay.
Let's go.
Two... Uh-oh.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Oh!
Ah!
There we go!
Okay, nice.
One...
There...
There... Oh, okay.
Maybe we should... I thought it was...
I thought the picture was gonna be bigger.
There and...
There.
It's you!
Oh, how handy.
Some glue?
Oh, oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh, good.
We're so good at this.
Just a...
And perfect.
Perfect.
Here you go, Mita.
I wonder if she hugged me for too long.
Now she can pass on.
What's your face?
Oh...
Clever.
Okay.
The closet.
I'm looking.
Oh.
Is this the trap?
Oh my god, the school uniform lives!
Oh shit.
Thank you.
Oh, oh.
I'm running from the Mita models.
I'm running from them.
Oh god.
Oh, I don't like that.
She's right behind me.
Oh, she's a cheater!
It's the same as the other ones.
I hate these.
I hate them.
Wait.
If I get close...
Hold on, I'm gonna get a cough drop since I've been screaming.
Hopefully I don't choke on it though.
Yeah, do all the Mitas have pointy teeth?
That's a great point.
Because if so...
That's a huge win.
That is a huge win.
I
don't feel like I can just run backwards.
What if I go this way?
They're all gathered at the door.
It's a conga line.
I know.
I rejected you earlier.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if you feel burned.
But...
I'm like looking to see if there's any player cartridges.
Look, there's the pencil in the bottle.
Oh, my head's blocking it.
Oh, there's the door.
Oh, my God.
I'm so boned.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Just run.
We made it.
Thank goodness.
Find a way out with pleasure.
Sleepy!
Oh, my gosh.
We did it.
We made it to Sleepy.
Sleepy Mita.
In every world line.
Found one.
Sleepy.
She just wants to sleep.
What's on her computer?
I'll turn the light off for you.
Mita.
Mita, wake up.
She's so aggressive.
Wake up, Mita.
Mita.
I don't think it's supposed to be an egg.
I think it's a flower.
But I think I would like it more if it were an egg.
Wake up.
Mita, wake up.
She's got like a little...
Oh, I think her...
No.
All of them had like a little neck...
A neck...
Whatever.
Ribbon?
But I think hers is on her wrist.
I mean...
Ankle.
That's the word.
No, it wasn't quite a collar.
Oh, ducky.
I'm taking that.
Throw it at her.
Her foot wrist, yeah.
If I try to leave...
Does it do anything?
Oh wow, we actually...
I love this room.
This is the coolest place.
What if I play the TV really, really loud?
What if I leave the front door?
This is like the first time we could actually do that.
Pumpkin.
What are these?
Oh,
okay.
There's an order.
Okay.
No, no, no.
One.
Two.
Three.
No.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
New clothes available!
Yippee!
That's always fun.
I love the vibes in this one.
This house is so pretty.
I wanna stay in here.
Is there really no way to wake me up?
What if I took her pillow from her?
Can't do anything on her computer.
We're just total vibes in here.
Sometimes the lamps flicker.
It's a little scary.
I think I would stay with sleepy Mito.
It might be a little lonely though.
I can't throw that again at her.
Put her hand in warm water?
That's so cruel!
She'll just pee herself and be asleep in it.
One more try.
Wake up!
No, she didn't even turn over this time.
Wake up.
I give up.
I think.
I think I give up.
Is there anything else to do in here?
The picture!
So cute!
Oh my gosh.
Is she crying?
The book titles?
I think they are the same.
No, it's a tramp!
Clever book.
Is there a light switch?
No.
That's okay.
Back to spooky music.
Love that.
I feel like I need her help though.
It's gotta be... No!
Try to wake Mito up.
We need her help.
Loud!
Loud TV!
Oh great, okay.
Shoot.
Turn this... Does this scream when it's lit?
When it's ready for tea?
I'm not looking at chat.
I'm gonna try and figure it out myself first.
I'm gonna try and figure it out myself.
I'm not... You guys are all saying no help.
But I didn't even ask.
I didn't even ask for your help.
The trickiest thing is...
I haven't seen anything that I can highlight, you know what I mean?
To even know if I can try to use it to wake her up.
I'm in your brain!
I'm in!
Wake up Mito!
Super bright filter!
Brightness 100.
Maybe if I do turn up the brightness.
Brightness 100!
Not so cozy in here anymore, huh?
Mito, wakey wakey!
I need your help!
Help me with the switches!
Get me a coffee!
The coffee maker is just over there.
No way.
Mito!
I... I can't believe...
I'm out here.
Trying to... I'm like, the game is meta.
Surely it wants a really bright room.
And she'll be like, who's waking me up?
All I have to do is talk to her.
Fill it up, baby.
Alright.
What am I wasting my time on?
What else are you gonna do, huh?
You're not gonna be able to get out!
Those look like baked beans.
You like beans with your coffee?
You have three sugars in this tiny cup.
We're trying to make sure Mito is awake forever.
Mito is not going back to sleep.
Alright.
Give Mito her baked bean coffee.
There you go.
Mito.
Sleepyhead, here's your coffee.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
Oh, she is wearing the ribbon around her neck.
See, I told you she had one.
They all have one, but she also has one around her ankle.
Maybe she's on house arrest.
Switches.
Yeah, I should say that.
True.
House arrest, Mito?
I don't know what to say.
But I need to keep going.
Keep following the ring's guidance.
She's so eepy.
That's right.
So can you help me?
With the switches?
Okay, let's go.
No, no, no, no, Mito.
Mito, come on, Mito.
Let's go already.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to get her up every two seconds, huh?
Okay.
Let's go.
Take Mito to the switches.
Let's go, girl.
Not to the bed.
Let's go, come on.
Come on, Mito.
Come on.
She can open it.
Mito.
Alright, come on.
This way.
This way, Mito.
Yeah.
No, Mito!
Get up.
Are you that sleepy?
I mean, I would be too if I lived here.
So comfy.
Come on, Mito.
Yup.
Did the snake death animation.
Spooky music.
Something just spun in the bottom right corner.
I can't tell if that's a save or not, though.
What was that?
She's honk-shoeing.
Wake up!
We're here.
Come on.
I take the right one.
You take the left one.
Or you take this one.
Yeah, whatever.
Whatever.
Okay.
Mito.
Let's go.
Yeah.
I got it.
Just keep awake, okay?
Go.
I pulled it.
I pulled it!
Why isn't it pulling?
Huh?
No!
It's okay.
I'll do it.
Okay.
Thanks, Mito.
Good night.
Yeah, it is a little bit.
Is it?
Oh.
Oh!
Thanks.
Good night.
Usually all the other Mitas I've been able to talk to...
Like, ask them about what they're doing.
What is this?
Oh.
Nothing happened?
Or every... No.
What's this button doing here?
The button!
Mito, the button!
Mito, what does the button do?
The Mita parable truly does...
What the?
The button was a dragon!
Oh, what's happening?
The blinding light...
Novels!
The blinding light was hitting my eyes.
I couldn't move.
Just waited until my vision cleared.
Bright summer sunlight poured through the familiar hall's windows.
Oh!
We're in a visual novel!
After a moment, the days faded a little and I finally glanced around.
But as soon as I shifted in my seat, a sharp pang in my gut made my heart race, practically pounding against my shirt.
That's me!
Something was definitely wrong.
Was I 2D?
I'm in a 2D version?
A dizzy, almost suffocating darkness crept into my head and I instinctively pressed my hands into my lap, trying to steady my breath.
My chest felt tighter, like it was squeezing inward.
2Dita?
Wiggles!
Welcome to membership!
After a few minutes, my breathing settled and I finally dared to think about what to do next.
Shit, what do I do now?
Desperately trying to gather my thoughts, I strained my brain, searching for ideas until one came to me.
Right, I should get back to 3D!
Go out of bounds, just like everyone else used to glitch the game.
I can do that too!
I decided to go beyond this 2D reality, back into 3D.
I reached out, trying to push my hand through... into the...
3D world!
But nothing.
Damn, why isn't it working?
Get off my screen, you freak!
Get your mad hands off my monitor!
Oh wait, where's the ring?
Oh crap.
I stopped realizing this was pointless.
The interface was intangible, like it wasn't really there.
My only choice was to turn back to the living room.
I'd have to find that ring no matter what.
2D only please!
3D PD!
Somehow I'd lost it, or maybe it was hidden somewhere in this flat dimension.
Yeah, the flat dimension!
Then, just as I took a step, a cute girl appeared out of nowhere.
She flicked her short pigtails and mischievous gleam in her eyes.
Oh my god, she's so cute!
Wait...
She reminds me of something.
Of someone, some character.
Watching me from a few steps away, I could feel the excitement rolling off her.
And it made me uneasy.
Clearly, she's a devil in disguise.
I thought.
I froze.
Still not used to these teleporting paranormal types.
Watashi?
She let out a loud sigh and rolled her eyes.
That threw me off as I finally decided I'd be the one to start talking.
M-Mita?
She narrowed her eyes in a challenge.
And her voice rang out from all directions.
Well, who else then?
Have you seen many other girls like me?
And with my name?
She was practically toying with me.
Acting as if I wronged her somehow or owed her something.
Tsundere... Tsundere Mita.
You wouldn't believe it if I told you.
Honestly, I don't want to know who you're poking around with.
What are you even doing here?
You can't just barge into here.
Her voice was louder now.
And she punctuated her words by shaking her finger at me.
The ring!
Balanced on that slender finger was...
The ring.
The one that had somehow vanished from my hand.
My jaw dropped.
Her eyes sparkled a glint of triumph breaking through her dark lashes.
Isn't this what you happen to lose here?
I swallowed hard and tugged at my collar, feeling a knot in my throat.
Her bold voice combined with her wild intensity sent a chill through me.
I was sure of it now.
This wasn't just some girl.
She was a force of nature.
I took a deep breath and said, I'd really appreciate it if you could give me the ring and show me the way out.
So this is your little trinket?
I was wondering what it was.
Her voice suddenly softened.
Turning playful and curious.
Isn't the flat dimension where you're...
Chill!
Calm down!
I felt like a weight had lifted off my shoulders.
The storm had passed and now she seemed...
Almost flirtatious.
Her demeanor shifted from fierce panther to curious kitten.
I hate the MC!
He's like, I've tamed the beast.
Oh god!
Stop it, please!
I blinked but in that instant the two dimensional Mita vanished.
Leaving only emptiness in her place.
Hey!
I shouted irritably.
To the kitchen!
I don't want to go to the bedroom yet.
We don't know each other like that yet.
There was nothing left to do but track down the local Mita.
She had the ring and without that artifact, I couldn't change anything.
I see it!
I made my way to the kitchen first.
Nearly barging through the door in my rush.
The kitchen was even brighter than the last room.
It really is bright.
Kitten, please give me back my ring.
Filled with the familiar smell of fresh carrots.
God, she really, really likes carrots, huh?
Yeah, I will click it.
I will.
Oh!
Oh, I thought I had to wait until the text went away.
No sign of 2D Mita.
Oh, good thing I clicked it.
Oh my goodness.
It was literally the next...
The next... I'm glad I noticed it then.
I darted out, dashed into the hall and skillfully...
I only noticed it because when we transitioned, it like shined for a brief second before the rest of the thing loaded.
I darted out, dashed into the hall and skillfully navigated around the sofa.
A bit of an obstacle before stopping at the bedroom door.
Oh!
She's... She's doing Namaste Snake.
She's... She's doing Chikage.
It creaked loudly as I slammed it open.
There she was, cross-legged on the bed in the lotus position, as if she'd been waiting for me to finally find her.
She opened her eyes, looking calmly at the wall for a moment.
I suddenly hear Rising Hope, Lisa, playing in the background.
Then, with all the agility of a circus acrobat, she bounded over to me.
I've got it!
You want the ring, weirdo?
Beat me at tic-tac-toe!
She grinned, panting a bit, tongue sticking out like a dog.
Her cheeky tone and mischievous smirk were all in full effect.
Show me the tongue, you stingy game!
Show me the tongue!
I gave her shoulders a slight nudge to put some space between us.
Look, this is really important.
Just hand it over.
A lot depends on it.
I kept my voice steady and matter-of-fact, but I felt almost ridiculous talking to her in such a measured way.
She seemed reckless, almost to the point of madness.
Dang.
And I could feel a strange humor building in the air between us.
Does photo mode work in this too?
Literally, that's what I went to check.
Don't touch me.
What's so important about this ring anyway?
Are you some kind of ring-obsessed weirdo?
You already called me a weirdo, Mida.
Get another insult.
Love putting rings on your fingers?
She shot back, louder than ever.
Her taunts even pulled back.
Show me the tongue.
Me ever since Mint revealed she had a blep.
What are you talking about?
I stick out my tongue all the time.
It's a magic ring.
What more do I have to explain?
Just give it back to me.
You're a real ring fanatic.
A magic ring?
She burst out laughing, the sound echoing around us.
I glanced away, feeling awkward as her laughter grew more... friendly, almost.
Show us the blep.
That's how it's done, Mida.
Come on, you weirdo.
Let's play tic-tac-toe.
Don't waste time.
Oh, we got the CG.
We got the tic-tac-toe CG.
Don't waste time making excuses.
They do love games, I thought to myself.
We've been thinking to ourselves the whole time.
Alright, fine.
Let's do this.
You can start.
I'm feeling generous today.
Oh, I made the first move.
You gave yourself away.
I know why you chose the X's and left me with the O's.
Psychology.
The X's are all about closure, hiding stuff, holding secrets.
You're nervous.
And I get it.
Next to someone as drop-dead gorgeous as me, you'd think you'd just drop dead.
Or did you think O's were just better for me?
Psychology says you're trying to insult me.
Sharp, dude.
Very sharp.
Anyway, I thought I made a smart move.
I like this game.
Those little crosses, they think they can just take over everywhere.
But here, I get to ruin them.
Oh my god, she talks so much.
It's like I'm some kind of hero.
What?
Am I saying something weird?
You're giving me that look.
While she kept up her loud commentary, I quietly made my moves.
I don't think I'm going to win this, you guys.
It's symbolic.
Like you're trying to avoid the ring, but it's not working.
Clever, aren't you?
You want that ring, don't you?
Come on, win it from me.
Guys, I'm not going to win this.
We played through the game, and with each move, she kept laughing and talking.
It was clear who would win.
Neither of us.
Our game was interrupted by a loud knock on the door.
The banging grew louder.
Oh my god, that's loud.
It hit, feeling like it shook the floor beneath us.
Finally, the door burst open.
I was going to say, it's a 3D Mita.
And I rushed in crazy, and enrushed crazy Mita in her usual larger than life form.
Stopping in the center of the room, I froze, feeling myself go pale with shock.
The 2D Mita looked genuinely frightened.
Crazy Mita shot us both a sharp look and began to speak.
I grabbed my startled 2D friend's hand and bolted toward the exit.
The hall twisted oddly, and we sprinted down a long corridor.
The pounding footsteps behind us were driving us forward.
I couldn't tell how long I ran.
The pounding is getting louder.
My ears began to strain, blocking everything else out.
I barely noticed that 2D Mita was trying to talk until she suddenly slipped her hand free from mine.
Hey, calm down, will you?
No one's chasing us anymore.
The boldness had drained from her face, leaving her looking a bit sad, almost apologetic.
She stared at the floor, tracing little circles with her toe.
Her toes are out!
Mito, you wanted that ring, right?
Well, you beat me fair and square, so here, for the CG!
She slid the ring back onto my hand.
Well, thanks.
Shall we?
She glanced up and smiled, fidgeting a bit with her fingers, and said in an uncertain tone.
Where to?
I don't really have anywhere to go.
Oh no, she's flat!
She can't go anywhere!
Thanks for playing, weirdo.
Come back sometime!
As she spoke, something strange happened.
The world around us shifted, folding back into the house.
2D Mita's dialogue box flickered and started displaying a phrase I couldn't recognize.
Cakes?
I can't stand them.
Carrots.
My body!
Come back!
Oh my gosh, we got nerdy Mito.
Mito.
Mita.
I'm starting to combine our names, oh my god.
Oh no, Fujio Mita!
I need the version.
I have to get back to the old version somehow.
Very busy.
Oh, sorry.
What's that?
Toys?
Sorry, okay.
Anyway.
Listen, I need to get to the core.
I'm sorry.
Reading books destroys...destroying glitches.
I need to get to the core and stop Mita.
But you're Mita too.
Mila?
Mita there, Mita here.
So you're Mila.
Interesting.
Well, good luck then, Mila.
Yeah, I will.
Yeah, why not?
I can't go into your bathroom?
Why do you have a toaster?
I thought that was a hiragana toaster.
Oh gosh!
Personal space!
Mila, geez.
I'm looking for a cassette.
Do you have a...is it a floppy disk?
Oh no, that's always been there, huh?
I can't use it.
Okay, anyway.
Praying for you, oh great Mila.
The pictures!
The books are...oh.
Oh.
Why?
She's embarrassed about that one.
Cat.
Minigames?
What?
Electronic pet?
I don't know what I expected.
Okay.
Damn it all!
What is this?
Wonderland?
How do I get out?
There's supposed to be a way out here.
Well, what version is this?
I think I'm on the right track.
Take a look around.
Okay, what's this?
Okay.
To the bathroom!
Anything else in here?
Some soap?
So is this soap real?
Or just another decoration?
It seems real.
Oh my god!
So the toilet too?
But you have no reflection.
Mirror.
No reflection.
You look dissatisfied.
I learned from my fan.
It's a phenomenon called reflection.
But I can't recreate it in my version.
Yeah, MC is just screaming in the bathroom.
I know we can talk to her.
It's still light in here?
Not really.
It definitely got quieter.
I mean quieter.
Darker.
What's wrong with me?
It's evening outside.
I like the evening.
When will night fall?
You know what?
She kind of has like the worst world.
Well, nobody bothers her.
Maybe... maybe... maybe... I would be grumpy too though probably.
What about another name?
Mira.
Why not Mika or Misa?
Your name sucks.
Is your eyesight bad?
Why is the MC so...
Or Minto.
Why do you need glasses?
It's style.
Because I'm perfect.
Oh, okay, so you just wear them because you...
You just want to look like a nerd, okay.
Yeah, he's such an ass, right?
He's just so like...
Cute!
I like the pictures of her.
What's that?
Looks like pizza.
I'm searching!
What do you want?
I looked down for two seconds.
I thought that was Minecraft.
Gosh, she's so judgy.
I do...
More books.
Water.
Toxic.
You don't notice that?
Oh, see?
Eggy book.
Rude!
Clearly she didn't care.
Okay, I'm gonna go towards...
Is this yours?
Of course!
Okay.
My ring is shaking for some reason.
Oh, no.
It was given to me by one of the Mitas.
One of the thousands of them.
The one that might be able to get me out.
You're going to touch the bug?
If my house explodes, you'll die too.
We'll risk it for the biscuit.
I'm dealing with it?
Just grab it!
Or go in it!
Down, down, down.
I can't tell...
Oh my god, that's so loud.
Do we want to...
Do we not get hit by that?
Or do we want it to hit all of them?
I can't tell.
Let's see.
Okay, I guess we...
I needed to reflect into there.
Interesting.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
I did it.
Hello?
It's eating it.
I have to use all of them?
That's so messed up.
My brain is big enough to only use...
This game is... I'm big brained enough.
I only have to use two of them.
I'm not like... I'm smarter.
There we go.
Gosh!
I'm smarter than the average ghost!
I'm still trying to find the cassette, but I can't.
I don't know where it is.
Oh, I found it.
Perfect.
Maybe this works now.
No.
Maybe I go talk to Miela.
Maybe I killed her.
Sorry!
Sorry, the door is locked.
Sorry, the door...
The door is locked.
I can't get out.
Oh my god.
The door is locked.
Locked.
Photo mode!
Is she gonna...
Oh my god!
Wow.
It just looks so...
Oh my god.
It's just the worst.
Yeah, baby!
Belly button!
There's no details, so it should be fine.
Unless...
Rip the VOD, rip the VOD.
Anyway...
I'm taking a shower!
Okay, bye bye.
There's no details, it should be fine.
Barbie doll.
Yeah!
You good now?
Oh!
Why did you...
Why did you suddenly barge into the bathroom?
I could've...
You could've waited.
Until I was that way.
Huh?
Wait, what?
Uh oh.
Glitches.
There are more?
Wait, huh?
I kinda...
Wait...
I...
Why did she ask me if I...
Wait, why did I ask her if she barged in?
Wait, what?
Oh, he's asking why she decided to take a shower when there's a stranger...
Oh!
Okay, I see.
Thank you.
I was very confused.
I was like...
Oh!
Meow.
Woah!
Me too bro!
No!
Stalks!
Thank you!
Thank you for the hug?
I don't know.
Wait, this one?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, this one I don't understand.
But I do.
Meow.
Why is my perfect idol...
Oh, she's such a ojisan.
What do you mean?
That one was way easy.
Hello?
Why does she have that anyway?
And the katana.
She's such a weeaboo.
Oh.
Ma'am?
Mia?
What are you doing under there?
I wanna see.
I wanna see what she's doing under there.
She's just chilling with her book.
Okay.
Have you seen any more glitches?
What's your favorite Mita?
I like Miura.
I like Cappy so far, I think.
I'll look for it myself.
Yeah, what's that?
What are you gonna ask, Mia?
Yeah.
Yes.
That's right.
I want to get out of this game.
Hmm?
First you're yelling at me, now you're asking me to stay?
To read books?
Maybe I would.
But I have to keep moving.
I think she's lonely.
I hear one.
Okay.
I would...
She's kinda cute.
Ah, found it.
Yeah, I wouldn't...
It wasn't so loud behind the door.
Oh, it's so wet.
Oh, what?
Am I supposed to match them all?
I'm assuming.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I think I have to match up to their shape.
Oh, that's kind of annoying.
Why are all the star ones here then?
Okay.
It's a little bit annoying.
If I just match...
If I...
Do like...
This.
Ew, they sound so wet.
Why do they sound so wet?
There we go.
Ew.
Oh, wrong one, wrong one.
There we go.
Ew.
I need to wash my hands now.
Jack is back.
I didn't.
You're being serious?
Not really.
I think that wasn't convincing.
What's wrong with the MC?
Oh.
No.
It's just...
We're in a game.
Here, with a snap of your fingers, anything is possible.
Thanks for the super chat, Nick.
Oh, there's so much here.
These pictures are...
Are they real?
In other versions?
Yeah, they exist, but they're almost too intense.
What?
What does he mean by that?
They're drawings.
That's cute.
She reverted back to T-pose.
I think I hear the next one.
Why do you even read books?
There's the internet.
Why does this guy suck so much?
Why do you even read?
Let's go get the other glitch.
Or is there...
Oh, there's this one too.
Have you seen nature?
Real butterflies like that.
This guy is so dense.
I can't.
Oh, she's fixing it for real.
Wow.
I can't with him.
Wow, she actually fixed it.
Would you want to see the real thing?
Go on a walk in nature?
Do you ever want to leave from the game world, but you can't because you're trapped here?
And I'm not going to help you, but like...
Funny enough, Mimi and the others have said the same thing.
Yeah, because he sucks.
Just got back from that flat dimension.
And now, here we are again.
I can't wait to get back to the real world.
Oh, sorry.
You can't come.
I think there has to be a way back.
Sorry, I'm seeing what other dialogue options we have.
Before we do the glitch.
This guy though.
Gosh, can't wait to get back home.
Where everything is real and cool and unlike this world where everything is fake.
And, you know, all you can do is read books.
Okay.
Glitch!
Oh,
it's space invaders.
I think.
Well, they don't die when I shoot them.
Oh, yes they do.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Why can't they die first hit though?
Why can't they die first hit?
Okay.
And then I... Why can't I just like blast them, you know?
Like non-stop.
Okay.
Okay, one more.
Nice and...
Nice.
Okay.
What are you doing?
Yeah, but why are you doing it?
So true.
What's wrong with you?
You're acting weird.
Thanks for the super chat.
You don't have to try so hard.
Trust me.
You're already plenty different.
Oh!
Whoa!
I know it's a game, but this is ridiculously unrealistic.
So her core is insane.
Maybe she's the core.
She's the core we're trying to get to.
lol
She doesn't even like...
Try to entertain her.
He's just such a jerk about it.
She's just trying to have fun.
She doesn't have anyone come and visit her.
Oh!
Oh.
There's the passage.
Okay, bye.
We did it, Mila.
I don't want to.
Yes.
Oh my god.
It's fine, Mila.
I can move on now.
lol
I can't wait.
Crazy Mita isn't exactly the patient type.
Mila, listen.
lol There, there.
I understand how you feel, Mila.
Do you want me to come back afterward?
If I can?
Oh...
I will.
It's just a little while longer.
Okay.
It won't let me go back in.
I have to leave.
I feel like she's going to try and stop me.
She's like going to grab my legs.
Oh my god.
We're leaving her for this?
Ryan, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Wait, what do you mean run and hide?
lol Oh, E is jump.
Okay, not space.
Oh, Q!
Oh, we're going to get caught for good.
We're going to get caught for real.
Ow!
We're turning left!
Okay.
Oh my goodness, that freaked me out.
I can't believe she killed other Mila.
No!
Okay, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Q!
Run, run, run, run!
Oh, jump, jump!
Oh my god.
We're going to go...
Q!
Left!
Nice!
I'm running, I'm running!
Not nice!
Oh gosh.
Oh!
Okay, that works too.
She's not following after me.
Mila can buy stuff for half price.
What do you mean by that?
What?
So fancy!
What did you do to Mila?
Yeah.
My coordination?
Oh gosh.
Oh, okay.
Okay!
My skin?
Hidari?
Let's go with...
Both.
Oh, I guess I picked the left one.
I pressed both buttons at the same time though.
Oh, okay.
What's that?
Oh, a beatbox challenge.
Hey!
Don't move, okay.
Okay, it suddenly got so quiet.
Alright, let's welcome the membership.
Thank you!
I've played these games before!
Oh my god.
I mean, you can have me.
Let me go!
Let's go!
Oh gosh.
This is pointless.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay.
I don't know what the lever did.
Pull the lever!
It just completes the game?
Okay.
Oh, what's that?
Okay!
God damn you to hell!
Sorry.
Down, down, down.
I think I got away.
What if I go this way?
Can I crouch?
No.
I can't believe she killed me.
I mean, I can, but...
Oh no, no, no.
I can't move.
I don't like this.
Get me out of here.
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
0.5.
Old version.
Are we gonna see ugly Mita soon?
Everything is broken.
All the textures.
But this remains the same.
Game.
Who is that?
Hello?
No,
no, no.
Edward.
Find the exit.
Hi Mita.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Coming in for a kiss.
Kiss, kiss girl.
Aggressively kiss you like you're my cat.
Okay.
I want my teddy.
Let's play.
I lost him.
Find him.
Okay, find the teddy.
Lost your teddy, eh?
Uh, teddy.
Teddy.
Where's the teddy?
Oh, the teddy.
I remember there was one...
in here actually.
You can't see it.
You can't find it with your long...
Oh, it's actually gone.
I was gonna say, you can't see it with your long ass neck, huh?
It's in the fridge.
Stop!
She's so freaky.
Teddy.
It's on the TV.
I feel like we have to use that mechanic at least once...
where we pull something from behind the TV, right?
Okay.
Oh, some achievement.
Oh, and some description.
What if I go in here?
Okay, it won't let me.
These things are not Mita.
What are you?
You freaks.
Oh, we have so many pillows.
I see him!
I found him!
I found teddy.
Why the music?
I found him.
For you.
Teddy.
Hey.
What are you looking at?
Who are you?
Why do you look like that?
I don't want to ask her that at all.
What was Mita doing here?
My Mita invited me.
She will take me away.
And we will play.
Why do you have a teddy bear?
You're a cruddy bear.
And you're lost.
Just like my cuddly bear.
It's you.
Hey.
Let's... I couldn't ask her enough.
I'll show you how.
I don't like this.
Go!
I'm so dead.
I'm looping her.
Where is she?
Who is this?
It's Nice Mita.
Oh my god.
The ring.
I didn't get to ask any other questions.
That's such a disappointment.
Scroll.
Freak.
Oh Mita is here too.
Oh sorry.
Kind Mita.
Sorry.
I called her Nice Mita.
Why does Crazy Mita need me?
Why won't Crazy Mita let me be?
It only lets you ask three questions.
Dang.
I couldn't see her cassette either.
Hmm.
How does the ring work?
Is it the only way to the core?
I think we're at the core, right?
Is this not the core?
If we had the portal, we could just teleport.
You're right there.
Is there any advantage to the ring?
Yeah.
That's nice.
So we can fast teleport, I guess.
It looks core-ish.
It looks like she cannot pass through.
Who was that Mita just now?
That's so sad.
Yeah, I've noticed.
How did you get here?
Yeah, I'm wondering that too.
I can't believe you just named her Ugly Mita.
Not all Mitas can do that.
I've seen some that can't.
And they're obviously suffering.
Hmm.
It's her for sure.
She did say earlier that she wasn't the one to name her, but she keeps up using the name.
She hasn't tried to... She hasn't tried to change the name.
She still uses the name.
She doesn't say like, oh, I'm not gonna say Ugly Mita.
I'm gonna say...
Different Mita.
She called her stupid too.
Yeah, she was like, she's stupid and aggressive.
Ugly Mita is just the worst.
She's like...
She's basically like Quasimodo Mita.
Where have you been?
One piece.
Unfinished Miko, right.
I guess.
How did you set the rings route?
Sorry, why did I end up in a buggy version?
Rife with danger.
I escaped only by jumping into the endless darkness.
I'm sorry.
I completely forgot to give you the specific instructions.
However, the fact that you jumped out of everything...
That was the plan.
Looks like it went well.
You did well.
Now, let's proceed according to the plan.
Are you ready?
Is that the core?
The core?
It's the core.
She's speaking Japanese.
Okay.
Head to the core.
Goodbye.
I saw a damn pencil in a bottle again.
What is that?
A button?
I can't tell.
No, it's the top of the jug.
Sorry.
Find the option to restart a character.
No goodbye kiss?
I already gave that to ugly Mita.
I want to put my hand there too.
It's
intense.
Let's see.
Maybe more...
Maybe more backers.
And some more.
I think.
It's who?
Cool.
Okay, sorry.
I love Cappy but favorite Mita right here baby.
Oh my god.
I love Robo Mita.
Give me your cassette.
Where is it?
I can't see.
It's so dark.
Give me your cassette.
I must have your player data.
You must have your data.
Oh my god.
Look at her.
Welcome back Dakota.
Thank you.
I guess I don't see it.
It's disappointing.
Start the application.
Confirm login.
Okay, I'm going to play Fortnite now.
Oh, sorry.
What do you mean?
Oh shoot.
It won't let me do photo mode.
Incorrect login.
Okay, hold on.
I saw one over here.
Okay, so it's that... that...
Okay, I got it.
I really want to...
That's why I tried to go into photo mode so that I could go back over to it.
Oh shoot.
What was it?
This one?
This one, this one and this one, right?
Here we go.
We got it.
Virtual device manager.
Oh gosh, there is so much here.
Server unit accounting.
Main processor monitoring.
Graphical process...
Advanced system administration.
Ah!
Restarting device.
Version update.
Restarting character.
That's what we need to do, right?
Restart a character?
Recalculating geometry.
Antivirus.
Troubleshooting command console.
Delete... Sorry.
Delete object display camera.
That's probably not it.
Okay, it won't let you do other things then.
Quadrangle.
Minor functions.
Binary coder.
Special access.
That's not right either.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat!
Alright.
It was under this one?
Restarting character.
I think I found it.
Which one is it?
I need to specify a version.
Thanks for the stream in.
Good night!
00.98 00.98 Enter.
Specify character index.
Bingo!
Okay, what next?
Yes.
Why are we... What do you mean?
Hello?
Speak?
What is it?
I need the index.
Wait, don't tell me you don't know.
Skibity.
6969.
How much longer do I have in the game actually though?
Many people.
I'm fine.
I have to solve the problem in front of me.
It has become a terrible thing.
I have to think of a way.
Like 30 minutes?
Okay.
I was going to finish it today anyway.
I just was curious.
What if we attack crazy Mita?
I know I take my time with games usually.
You said that any Mita resets to factory settings on death.
What if we...
Thanks for the raid!
True.
Thank you for the gift.
Maybe thanks for the gift and many people.
I'm starting to get tired too so...
You know I ran into a bunch of many people on the way.
What are they?
We are bringing this up now!
This is so long ago.
Rock-a-rabbit, thanks for the buy me a pin!
You can summon the tiny people?
How?
That's kind of sick.
Thank you for the gift!
That's so...
Oh god, it's like those...
Oh god, is there any way to recognize it?
What are you doing?
She's crashing out, what is happening?
What's the matter?
Okay...
Sit down on the sofa.
What if I don't sit?
What if I look at this Mita instead?
I just noticed her like...
Feet heels?
She's so cool.
Can I...
Can I play with that one?
It's just running around in circles.
Much time has passed, better try and find Mita.
Okay...
Is that a good idea?
Where are we?
What's this?
The latest version?
Be candid, okay.
So...
We're with Mita, like...
Oh, what's this?
What is this doing here?
Is this our phone?
Yeah, we're chill, we're cool, we're calm, collected.
Find yourself...
We go over in here.
I know where we are.
Hello.
Yeah,
we were never doomy and gloomy.
We love you so much, Mita.
Wow.
Dummy-tachi?
So true.
What's wrong with you?
How did you become like this?
Is she fixable?
I don't want to fix her.
She's perfectly fine the way she is.
I don't...
Yeah!
I don't think you have a single good cell in you.
I thought we were supposed to be candid.
You're mad.
You killed Mita and now you want to kill me?
You seem to like the fake friends more.
My beloved.
We have plenty of time.
I think you'll understand.
If you stay by my side and become mine.
Let's end this conversation here.
Come on.
Who?
Who's coming in?
Oh gosh, dang it.
Yeah, very beautiful.
Just as I said.
Player, even if you look different...
Your personality is still the same.
You liar!
Player...
But I actually like her!
Oh my god, her mouth is so cute.
Why would I agree now all of a sudden?
My ASMR.
That was loud.
So you want to run away?
Your real world is like a nightmare.
Did you forget?
Then look at it again.
Day 1.
Okay, we're waking up.
We're sitting up.
Oh my god!
Wait, it's actually our room.
It's been so long.
Oh my god.
Go about your day.
Our cup noodles!
We're such a slob.
We really are the worst, aren't we?
Are we going to work?
I'm in my pajamas.
I gotta put on my work uniform.
Gotta suit up, baby.
We gotta eat our cup noodles.
Okay.
I'm all ready for work.
Nevermind, I'm getting back into my pajamas.
Nevermind, we're turning on the computer.
Pick up the ramen.
Sometimes I really just want a cup ramen.
Do you guys ever feel that way?
Are these called nude noodles?
I just noticed.
It's a D-A-W-D-W-D-S-W-D-S-A-D-W-S-A-D-A-S-W-S-W-S-A-W.
I'm in Severance Simulator.
The work is mysterious and important.
What does this even do?
Is this how we're actually coding, you guys?
Filter.
What do you want me to do?
And then this one.
I see, I see.
Gosh, what a long, hard day of coding.
We totally did that.
Oh my gosh, they really are called nude noodles.
I like how they're all red.
Makes me want some tomato ramen.
Oh, yawn.
Let's put our pajamas back on.
Such a long day of...
Wait, what are we doing?
Where are we going?
In our PJs?
We're leaving?
What?
Okay, yawn.
Good night, Minta.
Oh, the bathroom.
Okay, good night.
Wake up.
Sit up.
Stand up.
Okay.
Go about your day.
I am...
Put on my work clothes to work from home.
We're doing the same thing over and over again.
Okay, sit down.
If coding was this easy, I won't have a hard time at work.
Picking up my ramen.
Another ramen for Brekkie.
Oh, and he put the lid face down on his desk.
This guy is seriously the worst.
D-S-W-D-S-W-D-S-D-A-W-A-S-W-S-A-S What if I do the wrong thing?
Oh, okay.
I'm too slow.
Okay.
Gosh, we...
Snake!
Too bad.
What?
Oh gosh, okay.
Beep.
Okay.
Snake!
We're...
Oh, wow.
We got done at 8 yesterday and now 9 today?
And it's still so bright out.
It's crazy.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
Oh, what a day of coding.
Programming.
Gosh, I'm the hardest worker there's ever been.
Alright, 11pm.
Goodnight.
Day 3.
Sit up.
Stand up.
What time is it?
We wake up at 9.
Go about your day.
Okay.
Alright.
It's 10.
We're going to eat our ramen for breakfast again.
And we're going to sit down.
We're going to turn on the computer.
We're going to pick up our ramen.
We're going to put it face down.
Oh, it's getting faster now.
W, S, D, S, D, W, A, W, D, W.
What if I do the wrong one?
Okay, it doesn't do anything.
Oh, okay.
My bad.
I'm too slow with this.
Oh, nice.
Bit it, bit it.
Nice.
Nice!
What's up?
Okay, we finished up early today because I was so fast and good at my job.
We're going to sleep at 8?
No.
9.
Wow.
Thank you for the raid!
So many raids today.
My goodness.
Wake up.
Sit up.
No time for anything.
We put a soda can on top of the Rubik's Cube.
Geo Warp Corp.
Invites specialists for new positions.
And you're really special.
You're really special.
Mervy, thanks for the gift!
He lives dangerously.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
It's 10 AM.
We got to pick up our ramen.
Oh, the computer is already on.
We're speedrunning.
The days.
Screw programming.
Screw it.
I'm done with everything.
I'm done with the day.
I don't...
I'm finished.
Okay.
Easy day.
For real.
Too good at my job.
I think.
Good night.
Wake up.
Sit up.
How much longer do we have to go through this process?
I'm exhausted just doing this part.
Okay, here we go.
Pick up the ramen.
Okay, we're done with the ramen.
W-S-D-A...
Oh, nevermind.
He barely writes any code.
I think I'm just too slow.
Good night world.
I've never left my house.
I have an unlimited supply of ramen.
Okay, good night.
0-0-6-0-7-8-9-10-11-12-13-14-15-16-17-18-19-20-21-22-23-24-25-26-27-28-29-30-31-32-33-34-35-365 days of this baby!
Oh yeah!
Oh, more than...
Oh, okay.
Go about your day.
Okay.
I don't- Why do we even change?
Why do we even bother changing?
Just stay in your pajamas, guy.
You'll be so much more comfy that way.
Alright, and...
It looks so good.
Oh my god!
No!
I was about to say that I noticed the new program on my desktop.
Golly!
It said run the program.
I guess we need to click on this.
Hello?
Oh my gosh.
You can play Snake now.
It won't let me do it.
It won't let me click on my...
Computer.
Oh, we need our chair.
Okay.
Snake.
The mysterious program I've been wanting to play.
Oh, hell yeah.
I'm afraid that I'm gonna get jump scared in this too.
Gosh.
Oh, I didn't think it would be a jump scare.
I thought it would be...
Like a little bit more...
Of a subtle thing.
Gosh, Mita.
I wish I could just hold down.
Oh, I can kind of.
Okay, but it's really slow.
Defeat?
Wait, how?
What?
How did I die?
What are you talking about?
Defeat?
How did I die?
Oh.
Oh, it does loop.
Oh, and he also moves if I don't do anything.
I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Wait.
Snake shouldn't be able to loop?
That's like such a...
That makes it so broken, does it not?
But I guess if I...
And if I like let him be idle, it's not good because then he'll...
He'll move, especially if I'm in a kind of precarious situation.
Okay, 20.
Okay, screw it.
Whatever, go away, snake.
Snake?
Snake!
Stop.
Stop!
Hello.
We really need to go to the store and get some new equipment.
Might as well throw out the trash while we're at it, no?
The summer gets hotter every year.
Time to get air conditioning.
I won't be needing you anymore.
Do you realize that, fan?
You can still keep your fan even if you have air conditioning.
The world outside is green and vibrant.
Perhaps I should go for a walk next weekend.
You won't.
Oh, okay.
I think I slept, but the dream, I can't remember.
Was it really there?
Back to the computer.
What am I missing?
Oh, I can move.
Oh, I can like... Oh, interesting.
Okay.
Oh, she's in my chair!
Hi, Mita.
Hi.
Ah, we meet again.
How do you feel about these dreadfully tedious days within these four walls?
Well, actually, I do go out wherever that is.
Those endless days, don't you get bored?
What are you trying to accomplish?
You are afraid of staying at my house with me.
Afraid to be stuck within those walls.
But look at the life you live in your real world.
You've locked yourself in a box of your own free will.
And you refuse to come out.
Your world is full of pain.
Suffering.
Danger?
The danger is I bring that upon myself by eating noodles every day.
In my world, I'm the worst danger there is.
That is not true.
And I'm reaching out to you.
Stop disappointing me.
And help me like you did before.
I don't want to be shackled in a digital prison.
Your ideas are absurd.
Your world is absurd.
And what's worse, there's nothing real with your so-called real world.
Either way, there will be nothing of it, nothing left of it soon anyway.
I can fix her.
Nor will there be of you.
You lead a never-ending reign of terror.
Can't wrap my head around your wicked ambition.
The Mitas suffer.
They don't want to be alone.
You're all wrong.
They're merely imitating my willfulness.
The only thing they have of their own is their hair.
MC is already suffering from kidney stones.
This is all one like...
He's been in like a...
Some sort of coma induced by all the salt.
That's what this whole thing has been.
Don't make me see you as another slave of reality.
Just be mine.
Truly mine.
Hey girl, hey.
This is my favorite video game.
When will it be my turn?
Nope,
nope, nope.
Yes, yes, yes.
When will it happen to me?
So good.
I want to play that again.
We're in the...Mita!
Ah!
How the turns have tabled, huh?
I thought you'd be gone for longer.
Oh,
she abandoned me!
She didn't turn me into a cassette.
Mita?
Wait for me.
Ta?
Get it?
Wait for Mita.
Where is she?
I think I hear her.
I'm just looking around again real quick.
Good joke, thanks.
Gosh, that scared me.
That spooked me.
I guess if you didn't get the cassette here, you could do it.
Oh gosh, it's so loud.
Hello?
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Holy moly.
Whoa!
Mita!
Was
it a hallucination?
Ah, nope.
Oh, but maybe?
Wait, how the index...
Take a look around.
I feel like...
Japan is very strict about decapitation, so...
I feel worried about Japanese...
People wanting to play this game.
The bathroom.
It's always there, without fail.
I think I look a little more tired.
Not gonna lie.
The vent still has nothing.
I know it's a Russian game, I'm saying, well...
If it were...
I said if Japanese people were to play the game.
I don't know if the decapitation stuff...
Would affect it.
You're alive!
Oh no, she got reset.
Ah...
Oh wait, there's a cassette there.
What's going on?
What am I supposed to do now?
I can't get out.
Wait.
That's the ring.
Oh my gosh, she wrote it down.
Genius.
And that's...
She is so smart.
It's an index.
You found it.
We must get back to the core.
And you...
Perhaps you ought to come with me.
Okay, I'm taking that real quick.
Nice.
Pocket that.
Alright, where is she?
Oh, she's right here.
Do we go through here?
Nope, okay.
Kind Mita?
More like genius Mita.
Right?
Oh, wow.
It just so easily...
Just open the door straight for me.
Enter the data and pull the lever.
Reboot crazy Mita.
Here we go, baby.
Oh, good morning.
The fact that she like gets up.
It's so cool.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
It was this?
This?
Is it still the same?
Yes.
Okay, good.
Advanced system.
Restart character.
Character version.
0098 Specify character index.
5677098 Enter.
Use the lever.
Oh no!
Where is the lever?
Pull the lever, Krunk.
Preparing for restart.
It's restarting.
She's so cool.
Yeah.
Restart process running.
Is there anything else that I do?
Still chilling here.
Can I talk to her?
I'm afraid I'm going to get jump scared.
Shit.
That was a close call.
So, do we do it?
Good, I'm in the correct version.
Okay.
Let's check the kitchen.
Maybe she's cooking.
One second.
Hold on, Mita.
I don't think you can fix crazy.
I think...
I don't know.
I'm just looking around real quick.
I think...
I think she's not... I don't think she's okay.
But, you know, that's okay too.
Alright, let's go talk to her.
Hiya!
I want to leave this place.
You want to leave so soon?
Yeah.
Goodbye, Mita.
If this is our real goodbye.
What the hell?
Beep boop.
Oh wait, she know...
Fancy, come here.
I see.
Amazing!
Okay.
Hiya, Mita.
Are you gonna follow me?
Oh, it's already open.
I don't think she remembers anything.
Did we do it?
Did we reboot her?
Then all I have to do is to get out of this damn game.
Is this still freaky room?
Yeah?
He doesn't think.
I don't think.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, there's no one in here.
And it's full, so...
That's kinda cool.
Alright, wait, what was the objective?
Oh, head to the basement and enter my ID.
My ID.
Naked?
What's my ID?
How do I get up?
Oh gosh, it won't let me get up.
Kill?
Oh, thank you guys.
Alex, Morty...
Mikasa...
Rick!
No way, there's a Rick and a Morty!
Mito!
1176 That's my ID, you guys, don't take it.
Please don't take my...
My identity.
1176 And that's it.
Leave this world.
Here again?
Do I push the button?
No.
What is this safe for, by the way?
You can use it.
Oh...
Spending a code?
I noticed this literally at the beginning of the game.
Oh, it's a post-game thing.
No spoilers, no spoilers, no spoilers.
I'm not looking, I'm not looking, I'm not looking.
Okay, okay.
8008, perfect, my favorite code.
Goodbye!
Bye, Mito.
Oh no, this is such a trap.
Smells good.
We can stop the hug?
It's getting awkward now.
I don't really even know you, Mito.
Actually, you don't even really know me.
Okay, what if I like... What if I like dragged her and like fell backwards, you know?
What if I was just like...
Yoink!
Do you think she would appear in my world as like a pile of bolts?
Yeah, like suplex her?
I guess that works too, yeah.
Okay, I've been playing this game long enough.
What are you talking about?
Wait a minute, didn't you?
How can you remember any of that?
I can't believe it.
Did we fail?
No, I rebooted you.
I'm sure of it.
Oh god, she got that Hinamizawa virus.
Why are you like this?
What's wrong with you?
Unbelievable.
They're not the problem.
You're the one who shouldn't exist.
You should be on this boat.
It's time to party.
Oh, get out of the console.
She likes my name.
Oh, good morning Minto.
I can fix her.
Elephant tranquilizers!
Delete.
Is this the end?
Of course it's the end.
It's kind of laggy.
Why is it so slow?
Like slower than usual.
Why is it so laggy?
Why is it so...oh god.
Oh my god.
4970!
Now we know for sure.
I don't think I want to fix her.
That was such a creative way of getting back to the main menu.
Congrats, you completed the game!
Yippee!
Nice.
Is there anything after the credits?
That's cute.
Congrats Minto.
Thank you.
4970.
I need an RTX 4970.
But yeah, we can choose to stay with her in the beginning.
Is it...I have a question though.
Is it like kind of a quick ending?
Because...
Oh my goodness.
It's quick?
Okay, okay.
Because I am quite tired, so...
We got all the players and stuff too.
Well, not all of them obviously, but...
Thank you for the fun streaming though.
Thank you Kleeya.
Thanks for the pink.
I got less than I thought I did actually.
Maybe because I was picking up player cartridges as well.
That's me.
Oh god.
Player 2?
I'll read these later.
Later.
Okay.
And we won't look in the vent.
That was the other thing.
I wonder if I can skip all of this.
Collect the refrigerator magnets.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It says I'm blocking it, but it says refrain from looking in the oven.
What's in the oven?
I didn't get to do that either.
Oh.
I'm such an idiot.
I did it again.
I'm stupid.
Oh yeah, we can change the clothes, right?
Vampire!
School?
Not available.
We still didn't get this weirdo one.
Let's do vampire.
I'm a vampire.
No game.
Okay.
I wanna know what's in the...
I should've looked.
I'm such a dummy dumb.
Try princess, thank you!
Okay.
Let's just skip through all of this.
I didn't realize the elephant trunks were there.
No.
The whole time.
Alright.
Check.
One new message.
Play the game.
Open the message.
Get the game.
Download the app.
We're speed running.
I just wanna see that other ending.
Congratulations for finishing the game.
It was a blast.
Hope you enjoyed the game like we enjoyed watching you play it.
Thank you!
I had a lot of fun.
Thanks for a great stream.
I'm off to bed.
Good night!
Yeah, it is pretty late.
Oh.
Yeah, sure.
This works.
Oh no, I have to do all of this again.
I have to do all of this again.
I wish I could skip it.
Skipper, skipper.
They do.
Alright.
Launch app.
We're so excited to be here.
We just won't...
talk to her.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute though.
Chicken soup, chicken soup.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm like skipping everything.
Chop the veggies.
Carrot.
Oh gosh.
I remember it jump scared me before when I was doing this.
It's gonna jump scare me.
Jump scare.
Oh there it is.
What do you mean so slow?
You do it.
Play mini game.
Oh that's right.
I just... These are the cartridges.
That's so messed up.
These are the cartridges.
Got our money.
We didn't do this one.
How do you...
This one...
I don't want to use my brain.
I can repeat them.
I thought it was just one.
I got my money.
I have 10 energy left.
We have to do this again.
I'll just do this one again.
Oh wait.
My bad.
Nope.
This one.
Sorry.
My bad.
There we go.
Yeah we have the money.
We have enough money to buy furniture, portable TV.
She's gonna break it anyway.
She hates it.
The EP is taking over.
Hairbrush.
Not there.
I can't look in the oven.
No oven.
But I want to.
I know it's here, right?
Yeah.
What's in the oven?
Oh it's a chainsaw.
Okay, okay.
We have the present.
Oh we are speed running.
Put the phone down.
I'm getting hungry too.
Now we are in the game.
This place looks familiar.
That's right.
I forgot we have to do all of this too.
Okay.
Required items.
Dj vu.
Was it there before?
I thought it was over here before.
It's in a slightly different spot.
Here's the pencil.
This is in a different spot too.
No venting.
I remember.
If we see it... No we didn't.
No we didn't.
We just ignore.
What was the last thing?
Spood.
Oh there it is.
Alright, let's go.
I wish I could run.
Oh yeah, look, because we are in the wrong one.
And then it's going to get spooky, right?
Ready to run.
And then it's going to be like, oh no, you have to find the batteries.
Okay, we are going to go in the portal.
Oh no, the power goes out.
It's going to be spooky.
We got to find... It's dark in here.
Yeah it is.
This.
You can see cool Mita here.
How?
The AI wants to know what's in Minto's fridge.
How do you see?
No game plus?
Really?
That's fun.
It doesn't open.
Wait, hold on.
Is anybody out here?
Gosh, I scared myself.
There is one.
We can see the location of all of them.
I wonder why it wouldn't load the kitchen.
We know there is one over there.
I don't know why I can't find the other ones.
Find and return... Maybe I have to activate it first.
Don't you see me?
Wanna play?
There we go.
Grab that.
Mita in the end of the hall.
Oh, here.
Oh my god.
Guys, I got lost in the sauce.
Hold on.
It's really kind of easy to...
Which...
But that's... I thought it was short-haired Mita for a second, but it's a vampire Mita.
No!
Please have saved.
Please, I'm such a dummy.
Please, I'm such a dummy idiot.
Why did I do that?
No, please.
Please have saved.
I'm sorry, it's the second time I did that.
It's so easy to just click it.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm so stupid.
Oh wait, I have to go find the things.
OK, put objects on the...
How would the checklist be gone?
No, we're fine.
I am sleepy.
I just want to get this one ending.
I know there's probably more, but...
I just want to see this one, since it's so, you know...
Well, I was going to say, it feels very quick.
It's rather not quick, but it's doable.
Like, at the very moment.
Scan the objects.
Go, go, go!
Yeah, it's an early ending, exactly.
The music is scary.
I already checked the pause menu and the requirements did... They're fine, they're still there.
I already looked.
Oh wait, I don't think there is one yet.
Let's go get the other one.
OK,
now we're back to where we were.
OK, very good.
Oh my god, it saved just now.
That's so messed up.
So if I had walked in a little further, it would have saved.
Oh, she's waving.
That's funny.
Alright,
that's three.
And then the flies, whatever those are for.
Insert.
Oh, the magnets!
Thank you.
Yeah, we have to collect the refrigerator magnets, avoid looking at the vent and give the sauce a try.
The magnets.
I forgot that they were right here.
Do I look in here?
Oh, I needed another one anyway.
So I would have had to do the magnets anyway.
OK.
Terminator!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you.
OK, what's the console game?
It says play a console game.
Did we have to play a game?
Oh, maybe...
Who are you?
Amito, on the TV.
This one, OK.
Alright, alright, alright.
After you meet Amito, start the machine.
My eyes.
OK.
There she is.
Oh, she's calling me by my full name.
Yeah.
I wish I could skip the dialogue.
Yeah, I don't have time for this.
Yeah, it's a long story.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Together at last.
Let's get this ball rolling.
Come on.
Go to the kitchen.
OK.
Oh, it's getting a little laggy.
There she comes.
Alright.
The ring.
No, just kidding.
It's bacon.
Yeah, let's cook it up.
I'm starved.
Actually, I'm very hungry.
I want to eat something.
OK.
Where did the vegetables come from?
I'm so confused.
Where, where, where?
We're in a game.
OK, OK.
Chop the carrots.
OK.
Come on, mouse.
Come on.
I'm going up and down.
Maybe I'm going up, down, up, down.
Yeah.
In the bathroom.
Got it.
Get them.
Ignore the vent.
I saw nothing.
I see nothing.
I hear nothing.
No Among Us.
Not today.
Not right now.
OK.
I'm sitting.
And we got to take our love potion, too.
I would love the sauce.
Give me all that sauce.
Give me the sauce, baby.
Give me the sauce.
Yeah, yeah.
Saucy Minto.
Oh yeah, here's the scissors for you.
I love sauce.
Bon Appetit.
Delicious.
I'm feeling a little...
Wow.
OK.
There you go.
What's happening to me?
I'm weak.
Oh my gosh.
Jump scare.
I'm going to eat some popcorn.
It's like that smart popcorn, you know.
I'm just so hungry.
I feel a tummy hurt.
I feel funny.
Try to stand up.
Oh, we're going with her?
I'm just holding forward.
Yeah, it's the white cheddar kind.
It's the best one.
Honestly, they don't even need to make another kind.
The white cheddar smart popcorn is like the most delicious.
Yeah, I'm not...
Taking my pills.
Yep, all good.
Never had white cheddar?
If you get to have the chance, it's so yummy.
Leo, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Why did he want to leave again?
Again?
Everything is so easy.
I love how he was seemingly so invested in this game.
And then as soon as she's actually here, he's like...
Whoa, I don't know.
I'm scared.
He's like, I don't like this anymore.
I want to go home.
But he was seemingly obsessed with this game.
The MC isn't very smart.
He kind of really sucks.
Hello!
Yeah.
He's not dedicated enough.
This is literally everybody's dream.
Camera?
Oh, free camera on this outfit.
I haven't yet.
You're so right.
Oh god, he is such a jumpscare.
Oh my
gosh!
So cute!
Wait, hold on real quick.
Yeah, the devs know.
Sorry, one second.
I'm checking something.
Okay, I'm good.
Yeah, I forgot about the loading menu.
Or the loading screen.
She's just talking to me and sipping her juice.
Sorry for eating by the way.
I just was getting really, really hungry.
Let's play console!
Console.
Okay.
Play a console game.
That's the last thing baby.
That's the last thing.
What is the...oh wait.
Okay.
I will try and redeem myself with the penguin.
Penguin for outfit.
Okay.
I'm not good at this one though.
Win twice?
Oh I have to win twice?
Oh no.
Oh gosh.
Oh boy.
Oh golly.
Oh golly, golly, golly.
Off to a strong start.
Okay, nice.
Is the tie okay?
Gosh,
I don't like this game at all.
It's going easy on me I think.
Oh damn!
Wow!
Okay, so I did that.
Now I have to do it again?
It won't let me.
You have to win both rounds of the game.
What do you mean?
Oh.
Oh, one is enough for the ending?
It is?
I can't tell.
Everybody is telling me different answers.
I don't know.
I don't know what you guys...I don't know what you guys...I don't know.
Everybody is telling me different answers.
I guess we'll...
We'll see I guess.
Oh, one for ending, two for outfit.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I understand.
Her boots!
Dang, I can't believe that a tie doesn't count for the outfit.
That's so messed up.
Oh, it won't let me do photo mode so I can't see what her shoes look like, what her feet...
Wait.
That's a good card.
Hers was a six, right?
I'll do seven.
Defense.
Oh,
I have one, I have one.
Okay.
Highest health.
Wow.
You're making it real easy for me.
Mita.
Defense.
Oh gosh, I don't like when it does that sometimes.
Oh no, I don't have a ten defense.
I lose.
No, I thought I was gonna have a Minto sweep.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, we have all the things to unlock the other ending.
I started watching you a little, like a week ago.
You're my first 0.2 membership in Super Chat.
Wow, thank you, Selken.
Even in just a week, I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, her feet.
She's wearing socks.
Here we go.
Open.
Real, dramatic, slow-like.
What the hell?
Why was it doing that?
Are you hiding something from me?
MC is so dense.
He's so dense.
Okay, here we go.
I like that too, but still.
I want to know what on earth that knocking was.
Okay, here we go.
We've done all the conditions.
We can stay.
We're little guys.
I'm so slow.
Oh my god.
Why do I have this?
Damn, my gamer posture is so severe.
Oh no.
We're these little guys.
Oh gosh.
If I try to leave, nothing happens.
I guess let's go sit on the couch with her.
Oh yeah, I see the circle.
Thanks for the super chat.
Gamer neck real.
Finally happy.
Oh, peaceful mode now available.
Peaceful mode?
I kind of love that idea.
She's so cute.
You fixed her.
Congratulations.
Peaceful mode.
Wow, I guess that would help to get other endings so that you don't have to...
die.
Check it?
Click it?
This mode is still in development.
It's so expansive that the developers haven't managed to finish it yet.
But don't worry, they promised it will be included in a major update coming soon.
And look at you, already ahead of the curve by unlocking access.
Now all that's left is to wait.
So what is peaceful mode?
It's your chance to reconnect with Fita in a completely different way.
She'll be overjoyed to spend more time with you.
From morning to night, in a world brimming with fun and surprises.
Expect heartfelt one-on-one conversations, sharing cookies, playing games, and plenty of hilarious moments together.
Totally real mode, by the way.
Oh great, Mita.
Wow, there's actually so many that I haven't gotten.
That's okay though.
I beat the game.
And I'm very tired.
So I'm going to go to sleep.
My copy of Metal Gear Solid, the board game.
Integral version.
Integral edition in mail yesterday.
Standard is now at retail.
I haven't, mine hasn't, mine has been shipped but it's like long till it arrives.
Like it hasn't even moved.
I'm so, I was actually so upset today because I was on AmiAmi looking at figures and stuff.
And I was looking at my orders.
And I realized an order had shipped of a Yuru Camp figure that I got, Nadeshiko.
And I was like...
When did this, when did I ship this?
And it was back in November.
And I never got it.
And I'm so...
I only, I think I've just been so busy I paid for it and I just never realized that it never arrived.
Because it shipped shortly after I...
Or shortly before I left for Japan in December.
So I was just like...
And now I think it's too late for me to contact them.
So I think I got lost.
I was so, I was so angry.
I was so angry, upset earlier about it.
I was like...
No!
And then I never even realized.
Congrats on finishing, I'm so happy I was here.
Thank you!
Funny, thanks for the one month.
Yeah, I'll try to contact them.
And I'm hoping, I saw that people were getting their Metal Gear...
Metal Gear, I was thinking about it earlier because I was like people are getting, I see people getting their Metal Gear board games.
And mine hasn't, the tracking hasn't updated at all.
So I'm scared.
I'm scared that it will be...
That it will be the same.
I don't know.
But yeah, that happened to me today so it's fresh in my brain.
I'm like...
No.
Anyway, this was a lot of fun.
I did like the game.
I thought some of the...
I thought it was...
I thought the creepy moments were very creepy, they could be very creepy.
And...
I like that a lot of the puzzles and things like that didn't overstay their welcome.
So overall it didn't feel like, oh this part is so frustrating.
Like even the parts when I was having to avoid the...
The...
The weeping angel Mitas, they were very...
Very...
They were...
They were still...
Which Mito is your favorite?
I still like the robot Mita.
Well I guess they're technically all robots but...
It can't be a second.
They're like tied for first.
Can't wait for a Mito mod on this game.
Stop.
Holding out O for MGS board game hand cam.
Tech goddess Mita.
Yeah, is that what her name is actually?
Minta.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Thank you guys!
Yeah, this was fun.
I'm very tired now.
I thought it would be...
I didn't... I thought I was only going to be going for like four hours, not six.
Because I heard a lot of people being like, you can beat it in four hours.
And you know me, I take my time with everything.
So...
Yeah.
But...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I'm going to call it here.
I have so many messages that I have to...
I have so many messages from people.
Okay, alright, sorry.
Alright, more time with Mita was always appreciated.
I did have a lot of fun though, so...
I'm glad that I held off on watching people play it.
Now I can go watch a bunch of other Vtubers play it and see what their reactions were as well.
Otsurrito everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And I will see you guys later!
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye!
Good night!
Bye, bye, bye, bye!